Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, hauptsächlich von mir, hauptsächlich von
Donetschland.
Erster, tatsächlich, wobei der Phipps 2, der war schon da vor einer Stunde habe ich im
Chat gesehen, was ja immer noch am Start ist.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Videos habt, die wir unbedingt gucken müssen, dann sagt mal Bescheid,
so ergiebig war YouTube nicht.
Und auch das was ich mir die Woche über gespeichert habe, es sind nicht wahnsinnig viele interessante
Videos dabei gewesen.
Im Zweifelsfall bin ich eh nach dem zweiten Video side tracked und laber 45 Minuten über
irgendwas.
Kann ja schon sein, aber vielleicht auch nicht.
Brötchen zwei Stück, eins mit Nutella, eins mit Käse, wie man auf hessisch so schön sagt.
Mit Käse.
Sachen die wir schaffen müssen, ich mag keine Videos die hochkant gedreht sind, ich weiß
ich ist richtig in Boomer Aussage, aber die ganzen Shorts Ding, da sind zwar teilweise
lustige Sachen dabei, aber ich cringe immer noch oder ich paint Champ jedes Mal bei hochkant
gedrehten Videos.
Wie gesagt auf hessisch heißt es mit Käse, oder mit Käse mit Käse, wenn du was über
Züge und Stuttgart 21 gucken willst, nein ich glaube heute nicht.
Was macht eigentlich so die Bahnseck, Bahnstreik, wie sieht das da gerade aus, bis wann Bahnstreik,
gute Frage Google, das frage ich mich auch, da fehlen zwar ein paar Wörter, das ist so
typische Twitter, bis wann Bahnstreik, die wichtigsten Wörter für den Satz sind drinnen,
dass man sie versteht.
Jeder Progas hat einen hochkant Monitor, ich habe sogar zwei Monitor die ich hochkant stellen
kann, aber ich stelle die nie hochkant, da muss ich ja sonst wohin gucken.
Ich überlege so was ist das 27 Zoll, ich glaube 24 Zoll, wenn ich den hochkant stellen
muss ich ja sonst fast an die Decke gucken, dass ich das sehe, ok, also bis wann Bahnstreik,
aktuell gar kein Bahnstreik oder, ja weil ich muss nächste Woche Dienstag mal wieder
auf die Arbeit fahren.
Ja am 31. stelle ich mal vor, muss ich wieder nach Frankfurt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton
Store, zahl die Kollektion barfick auf Sponsor, da muss ich hin, nicht in die Louis Vuitton
Store, aber in die Goethe-Straße, nee ehrlich gesagt muss ich nicht in die Goethe-Straße,
ich muss zwei Straßen breiter, aber fast Goethe-Straße, ja und das wäre natürlich äußerst blöd
wenn dann die Bahn streikt, da muss ich doch mit meinem super agilen Auto nach Frankfurt,
nee das mache ich nicht, aber ich fahre dann einfach einen Tag später, Ricksbus genau,
auch ohne Streik fährt die Bahn kacke, ja gut das ist ja nichts neues, das ist ja nichts
neues, aber mit Streik ist, wie ist denn das, so meiner Erfahrung nach würde ich fast sagen
mit Streik sind dann die Züge, die fahren auch pünktlicher, weil weniger los ist, ich
kann mich an den letzten Streik aber nur noch dunkel erinnern, ich weiß, dass ich übelst
rumgeranged habe und auf Twitter die Bahn beleidigt habe, ich weiß, was die Bahn sich
von mir auf Twitter schon anhören musste, ist auch nicht normal, wenn die mich verklagen
wollen, hätten sie mich schon längst verklagen können wegen irgendwelcher, ich bin da teilweise
schon ein wenig über die Strecke geschlagen, ja, wie ich die teilweise angeflammt, aber
gut ich meine dann bin ich, ich bin dann auch echt stinkig, man hat ja keinen Bock sinnlos
rumzustehen und nicht zu wissen wo es weiter geht, da habe ich die schon geflammt, wobei
ich muss sagen, ich schreibe ja immer dabei, ihr auf Twitter könnt nichts dafür, ich weiß,
dass ihr auf Twitter nichts dafür könnt, ist ja auch so, die auf Twitter können ja
nichts dafür, wer bei der Bahn was dafür kann sind irgendwelche Stonks Manager Typen,
vor allem, ich wollte kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen und vor allem die Entscheidung
vor ein paar Jahren oder vor Jahrzehnten, ich weiß gar nicht wann das genau getroffen
wurde, dass man die Bahn doch an die Börse bringen will und dementsprechend die Bahn
so profitabel wie möglich machen muss und daraufhin sogar gesagt hat, wir bauen Stellen,
äh nicht Stellen, Stellen auch, aber wir bauen Kleise und Stellwerke und Bahnhöfe
bauen wir weiter zurück, was halt totaler Witz ist, wenn man sich überlegt, jetzt muss
man den ganzen Scheiß aufholen wieder und noch mehr bauen, weil es nicht funktioniert,
gerade so Strecken wie Frankfurt, Köln und so, die kannst du ja wohl, ich glaube, ist
Frankfurt, Köln nicht die oder zumindest eine der meistbefahrenen Bahnstrecken überhaupt,
also weltweit keine Ahnung, aber in Deutschland, ich glaube Frankfurt, Köln ist richtig voll,
es platzt.
Zumindest weiß ich, dass unter der Bahnstrecke oder neben der Bahnstrecke, in der Nähe
von der Bahn, ich glaube unter der Bahnstrecke, äh unter der Bahnstrecke, Köln, Frankfurt
sind ganz viele Glasfaserkabel verlegt für Internetstells, wobei nicht unbedingt Internet,
Backbone Zeug zum größten Teil, ob da jetzt Internet Sachen mit zu weis, weiß man ja
nicht, aber vieles wahrscheinlich schon, ja, wie gesagt, ich hab nix dagegen, das muss
ich jetzt auch nochmal sagen, ich hab nix dagegen, dass die GDL streikt, so in Form
von, dass ich sagen würde, man sollte ihnen verbieten zu streiken oder sowas, ich bin
in der Meinung, wir verbieten schon viel zu viel, aber ich muss aber auch im Gegenzug
nicht sagen, ich find's toll, dass sie streiken, ja, ich sag ihr dürft streiken, aber ehrlich
gesagt, mir geht's voll am Arsch vorbei, solange der Kram fährt und ich find alles
scheiße, was dafür sorgt, dass es nicht fährt, unter anderem, dass die GDL streikt, auch
wenn sie streiken dürfen.
Der einzige, mit dem ich da solidarisch bin, sind die Leute, die von A nach B kommen wollen
pünktlich, weder mit der Bahn noch mit der GDL, die können mich alle mal.
Das würd ich mir bei manchen tatsächlich, kann ich mir das sogar vorstellen.
Ne, was sollen sie denn sonst machen, wo willst du denn in Deutschland als Bahn, als Lokführer
groß hin, wenn nicht zur Bahn, da gibt's ja wahrscheinlich nicht so viel, ich mein,
du kannst zu irgendwelchen hessischen Landesbahnen oder sonst was, aber ansonsten im großen Stil
gibt's doch nur bei der Bahn was, ich glaub, du hast gar keine so große Chancen, da irgendwo
anders hinzugehen.
Mit der Bahn in den Urlaub, echt, wo fährt man hin, du meinst zum Flughafen oder wirklich
in das Urlaubsland mit der Bahn, auf die Idee bin ich noch nie gekommen, das würd ich auch
nicht freiwillig machen.
Als du bei deinem Opa in die Wohnung gezogen bist, also muss ich sagen, das ist keine Wohnung,
das ist ein komplettes Haus mit Keller, Erdgeschoss, ersten Stock und Dach.
Also Wohnung ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig, weil Wohnung suggeriert so, man könnte da
ohne Probleme mal neue Kabel legen so quer durch, das ist ja schwierig.
Waren da die Netzwerkdosen schon installiert oder hat das der Elektriker eingebaut, überlege
mir auch im Haus Netzwerk in die Räumlichkeiten zu verbauen, also, nein, das war noch nicht
eingebaut, mein Opa hatte selbstverständlich keine Netzwerkdosen, mein Opa hatte auch
keinen Serverraum und mein Opa hatte auch hier oben weniger Räume als ich jetzt, weil
ich hab beispielsweise das Wohnzimmer gesplittert in Büro und Schlafzimmer, weil ich nicht
so ein großes Arbeitszimmer oder ein großes Schlafzimmer gebraucht hätte, da wo früher
das Schlafzimmer war, ist oben das Wohnzimmer drinne, dort wo das Bad drinne ist, ist jetzt
mal eine Küche drinne, ich habe so eine Mini Küche hier oben, wir haben eine große unten
und dort wo früher die Küche von der Oma war, ist jetzt zur Hälfte mein Bad und zur
anderen Hälfte Vorratsschrank, ja, also das war noch nicht da und das haben Elektriker
gemacht, allerdings, ich hab den nicht richtig zugeguckt, sonst, also hätte ich den richtig
zugeguckt und hätte mir damals Gedanken drüber gemacht, dann hätte ich ein paar Sachen anders
gemacht und zwar erstens, hätte ich gesagt, die sollen das Zeug ordentlich machen, ordentlich
beschriften, haben sie nicht gemacht, ich hatte ganz schön viel Stress rauszubekommen,
welches Kabel wo genau hingeht und welche Anschlüsse wie wo belegt sind, so und das
nächste war, dass sie es unten auch nicht ordentlich gemacht haben, beispielsweise im
Schaltschrank, ist nicht etwa so, dass die Tür-Gegensprechanlage, die beiden Telefone
irgendwie ordentlich mit irgendeiner Vago-Klemme oder sonst wie zusammengeklemmt sind, nein,
die sind zusammen gedrillt und dann Isolierband drumherum gewickelt, also das finde ich, finde
ich sehr pains-champig von einem professionellen Elektriker, was sie da getrieben haben, so
und ja und der größte Punkt ist eigentlich, ich würde mir heutzutage mehr Leerrohre reinbauen
lassen, da hab ich damals nicht dran gedacht, ich hab aktuell nur ein Leerrohr liegen zwischen
im Flur, zwischen ersten und zweiten Stock im Flur, das ist doof, ja das hätte ich anders
machen müssen, ja so siehts aus, von Norden in die Alten dann zu Fuß über die Alten,
das ist ne gute Idee, Wanderställs, exellent, da muss man aber fit sein, ich mein ich bin
ja auch unter die Wanderer gegangen, so die letzten 3-4 Jahre schon, post ja auch immer
ab und zu mal auf Twitter irgendwelche Landschaftsdinger, wo sich die Leute dann immer fragen, was
mach ich denn an der frischen Luft, aber das würde ich mir nicht zutrauen, mein Opa hatte
keinen, aber mein Opa hatte nen Fahrstuhl, so nen Fahrstuhl hattet ihr, habt ihr garantiert
nicht, Moment, Haus, auf der Baustelle, Zack, hier, pass mal auf Fahrstuhl, Fahrstuhl, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
da war der Fahrstuhl schon weg, Moment, da war der Fahrstuhl schon weg, Baustelle, Moment,
Moment, auf der Baustelle im Gartenställs, News von der Baustelle, wo hab ich das denn,
hier Fahrstuhl, Max zeigt den Fahrstuhl, nein, ok Dach, irgendwas mit Dach, Dachbodenställs,
ok hier, jetzt kommt der Fahrstuhl, jetzt kommt der Fahrstuhl, vor 8 Jahren, ja, das
ist 7, das ist 8, 8, 9, das ist 9 Jahre her, kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen, richtig,
ne, 9 Jahre, tatsächlich, ja, da war ich 25, ne, ich bin 37, ich war 26, ne, kann ich
rechnen, gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, 28, so, hier Fahrstuhl, guck mal, sowas, sowas
der Opa hatte keinen Serverraum, der Opa hatte aber einen Fahrstuhl, einen selbstgebauten,
äußerst abenteuerlichen Fahrstuhl, hier ist auch schon mal was draufgekracht von Opa,
den gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, weil ihr seht es ja hier am Anfang, ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
das ist ein wenig Pains Champ zu isolieren gewesen, schwenkt mal rauf Max, guck mal,
wie wollt ihr das isolieren, no way, das isoliert man nicht so einfach, das ist einfach mal
ein großes Loch in der Decke, einfach ein riesen Loch in der Decke, so, und jetzt fahren
wir mal rauf, genau, ich mein, aber eins muss man meinem Opa echt zugute halten, der hat
das alles selbst gebaut, komplett selbst, also das Metallzeug selbst gemacht, die Elektronik
am Verschluss selbst gemacht, ja, der Opa hatte ganz viele Bilder von nackischen Mädels
auf dem Dachboden, also der war ja künstlerisch recht begabt und hat Portraits und wie nennt
man das, Portrait ist ja nur das Gesicht, wie heißt denn das, wie heißt denn das, wenn
man jemanden komplett malt, so, nicht Portrait, sondern, ja, so, so komplett, Akt, ja Akt
ist ja nur nackig, wie heißt denn das, wenn man so eine Person komplett malt, zumindest
hat er Opossum-Kopf, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, zumindest hat er halt viele Leute gemalt
und halt auch Mädels und natürlich auch nackige Mädels, Gemälde, nein, das ist ein Gemälde,
aber wie sich das halt nennt, wenn man Personen malt, ich weiß es nicht, so, und ach so,
genau, hier, hier jetzt das hochfahren, das ist richtig abenteuerlich, guck mal, der hat
hier, also jetzt hab ich zugemacht, so, zu, jetzt drückt man da nach vorne nen Knopf,
da, genau hoch runter Knopf, ich mein für selbst gebaut ist das doch wirklich nice,
ich mein wir haben es wegmachen müssen, das Isolieren vom Dach war halt absolut nicht
notwendig, äh nicht möglich, auch wenn ich das gerne behalten hätte, der Motor steht
nur oben, ja, und jetzt das hängt alles an einer, an einem Seil hängt das alles dieser
komplette Fahrstuhl, passt mal auf, ich versuch euch das mal, guck mal, man das sieht, wenn
ich wieder einsteige, Ganzkörperbild, ja sowas, genau, Halbprofil, so, so, genau, zeig mal,
zeig, zeig, zeig, hier, ne, das ist die Elektronik, hier, das hängt, dieses ganze Fahrstuhl inklusive
mir, also Fahrstuhl plus ich hängt an diesem Seil dran, und das hatte auch, das hatte auch
seit wahrscheinlich 50 Jahren keiner mehr geschmiert oder so, und da unten drunter
ist der Motor, wobei der das schon echt clever gemacht hat, muss man ihm sagen, ne, so ein
bisschen Flaschenzug-Style, dass der Motor quasi mehr und mehr heben kann, auf den Dachboden
kommst du mit einer Leiter jetzt, ja, darf man das heutzutage noch machen, ich glaube,
ähm, dass, darf man wahrscheinlich, durfte man damals wahrscheinlich auch nicht bauen,
da hat er immer, was TÜV angeht, da hat der Opa immer gerne Story erzählt, nur mal so
ganz kurz zusammengefasst, der musste wohl, als sie das Haus umgebaut haben, musste dann
auch irgendwie einer vom Amt kommen und sich die Umbaumaßnahmen angucken, so, und der war
wohl da, und hat ihm gesagt, dass sein Geländer 5 cm irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zu kurz ist,
oder irgendwie sowas, und dass er irgendwie ein paar Wochen wieder kommt und kontrolliert,
ob das Geländer jetzt richtig ist, so, und dann hatte Opa, das ist jetzt die Story, hat
er halt immer erzählt, dann hatte Opa unten ans Geländer noch einen Aufsatz dran gemacht,
dass es jetzt 5 cm länger ist, dann kam der Typ dran, dann kam der Typ wieder, hat das
abgenommen, und als der weg war, hat das halt wieder abgeschnitten, klingt jetzt für unsere
Verhältnisse irgendwie übelst Resident Sleeper Story, aber die hat er mir bestimmt 200 mal
erzählt, und ich glaube, ich glaube, ähm, für den war das damals voll, voll Adrenalin
aufreiben, so, weil Gesetzesverstoß und so, wobei, hey, kannste nix sagen, mein Opa
hat einiges hinter sich gehabt, also der war da abgehärtet, so, genau, hier hängt der
ganze Fahrstuhl dran, der hat den TÜV gehackt, genau, TÜV-Prüfer hassen diesen Trick, ja,
hier ist alles weg jetzt, ja, wie gesagt, auf den Dach kommen wir noch hier, Billigwerkzeug,
würde mir das bei mir anders aussehen, exzellent, genau, ja, und der hatte sogar hier unten
drunter, hatte der sogar, ich glaube, hier irgendwo, hier unter dieser Klappe, da konnte
man runterklettern, wenn der Fahrstuhl kaputt ist, also der hat sogar einen Notausstieg
gebaut, wenn man das hoch macht, das konnte man hochklappen und dann konnte man runterklettern,
so, naja, man konnte nicht runterklettern, falls fast 3 Meter hoch ist, aber man hätte
mit einer Leiter rausklettern können, wenn der Fahrstuhl kaputt gegangen wäre, also
der hatte einiges gedacht und ja, das ist nicht ohne, gerade, wie es hier im Chat geschrieben
hat, das ist richtig Big Brain gewesen, also wir haben, so prinzipiell, die Sachen sind
immer noch da, also die Leisten hier oben sind noch da, ich meine, unten nicht mehr,
weil da muss ja jetzt ja die Klappe rein, die Leisten oben sind noch da, die Räder
sind noch da und der Motor ist auch noch da, aber, ja, ich werde da nie wieder den Fahrstuhl
hin bauen oder so, ja, genau, die Klappe konnten wir aufmachen zum Absteigen und jetzt
runterfahren, einfach random, so ein Rollstuhl hinten rumsteht und man muss dazu sagen, der
Opa konnte ja noch nicht im Internet nachgucken, so, how to, bla, bla, bla, da musste das alles
selbst machen, das hat er irgendwie, was weiß ich, 1950 oder so gebaut, ah nee, ein bisschen
später, aber 1960 vielleicht, 1950 kann ich sein, der war ja im zweiten Weltkrieg und
der war ja 45 oder so, erst wieder da, dann musste er ja noch die Oma kennenlernen und
dann in das Haus, also, 1950 ist vielleicht busy, busy knapp, so eher 1960 oder so, weil
er das gebaut hat, was hat er gelernt, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was mein Opa genau
gelernt hat, er hat nicht Elektriker gelernt, er hat aber irgendwie Baumaschinen, Mechaniker
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das genau so hieß, was
der gemacht hat, Industriemechaniker, irgendwie sowas, ja, da wird Big Brain Time wird da
erklärt, ja und wie gesagt, es hängt das komplette Gewicht inklusive mir und dem Fahrstuhl
hängt gerade an diesem Seil dran, hatte ich damals noch dünnere Finger, das muss der
Winkel sein, ja wunderbar, so siehts aus, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was der Opa gelernt hat und ich kann jetzt auch nicht mehr fragen, ja, ich weiß es nicht
genau, irgendwas Industrie, Industrieanlagen, Mechaniker oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung,
der Typ ist lustig, die Videos von dem Typ krieg ich immer empfohlen, die Videos krieg
ich immer als Shorts empfohlen, weiß auch nicht, das ist ja fast schon Pedobear Warning
hier, ach du Scheiße, das ist ja schon fast Toss, Alter, ok, das ist Fake, aber trotzdem,
der Typ hat teilweise übelst lustige Videos, ja ok, das ist dumm, aber der hat teilweise
übelst lustige Videos, aktuell ist er anscheinend dabei, irgendwelche Discord Girls zu Speedrun,
was auch immer, keine Ahnung, Weird Side of YouTube wieder, ja, der YouTube Shorts ist
wirklich so ein Ding für sich, wobei ich nicht verstehe, was der Reiz an YouTube Shorts
ist, weil 90% davon ist einfach TikTok-Content hochgeladen auf YouTube, die sind ja teilweise
so faul und entfernen doch nicht mal das TikTok-Logo, gut, ich meine, na doch, wobei ich verstehe
es ja schon, man kann TikTok gucken ohne TikTok zu haben, im Endeffekt auf YouTube Shorts,
was ist eigentlich aus Twitter, wie hieß das, Twitter Stories, Twitter Shorts, Twitter hatte
doch auch sowas wie Shorts, das hat bloß keine Sau interessiert, muss man echt sagen, absolut
keine Sau interessiert, ich weiß gar nicht mehr schon, wie das hieß, Twitter, hieß
das Stories, ach gibt's das nicht mehr, ja das wundert mich nicht, das hat ja keiner
verwendet, Fleets, Fleets hieß das, genau, du könntest mal ein Video über Passwortmanager
machen, ja gut, da kann ich nicht allzu viel sagen, ich verwende KeyPass einfach seit 100
Jahren, also hier nicht, aber auf dem anderen Account und das funktioniert, hast du das
schon gesehen, Opnei, iHide&Seek, ja, ja, ja, das habe ich schon gesehen, wisst ihr was
Leute, wir lassen uns jetzt mal eine Runde von LevelCaptchibaten, die haben einen Audio-Chatraum
auf Twitter, wirklich, wie mache ich denn einen Audio-Chatraum, gehen wir mal zum Frazier,
ops, nicht Twitch, Twitter, wo gibt's hier Audio-Chaträume, oh nein, ich hab mir die
Trends angeguckt in Deutschland, please, Lockdown für Ungeinführ, jetzt geht's schon wieder
los, ich darf mir die deutschen Trends nicht angucken, das triggert mich immer, egal was
ich sehe, Audio-Live-Streams auf Twitter, ok, die wissen auch noch mal was sie machen sollen,
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an das Streaming-Feature auf Reddit, kennt ihr das Streaming-Feature,
Reddit, manchmal wenn man auf Reddit geht, keine Ahnung, gehen wir zum Beispiel auf
das C-Sharp-Subreddit, irgendwo hin, dann hast du teilweise, wenn du das aufmachst,
so, da kommen dann random immer die Empfehlungen, diesen Videostream jetzt anschauen und dann
sind da irgendwelche Leute, die spielen Gitarre und ihre Katze ist im Bild und so, wo ich mich
immer frage, was genau ist dieses, was möchte mir dieses Reddit-Streaming-Feature sagen?
Ich hab's bis heute nicht verstanden, was der Sinn von diesem Reddit-Streaming-Feature
ist.
Ja, guck mal, Reddit, komm, ok, dann kriegen wir gleich irgendwelche komischen Dinger empfohlen.
Germany, ne, Germany sucks natürlich, wieder mal, was es da gibt, ich trau mich immer nicht
über die Startseite zu scrollen hier, kompakt, vielleicht muss man dazu auch, doch hier guck,
top Livestream, das klickst du jetzt an und dann kommt irgendwelche random Dinger und
ich verstehe dieses Feature nicht, du kriegst auch immer so random Livestreams empfohlen
von Dinger und so, das nichts mit dir zu tun hat, ich verstehe das Feature nicht, ok, Frankfurt,
was ist in Frankfurt los, zeig mal kurz, ein Blick, ein Blick nach Frankfurt, mehr Viewer
als du, ja gut, ist ja auch keine Kunst, so, Frankfurt, News Events in Frankfurt are mine
and area, Löte Straße, Louis Vuitton Store, zahl die Kollektion barf, pick auf Sponsor,
alles klar, alles klar, langweilig, gut, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ich wollte mir,
ich wollte mich von Levelcap, Levelcap Jibane lassen glaube ich, stand das da auf Reddit,
stand das da auf Reddit, Reddit, wundert mich nicht, wundert mich nicht, frisch, ich will
mir da gar nichts genauer drunter vorstellen, was Reddit da wieder treibt, Chat was kostet
es einen Internetanschluss zu verlegen lassen, wohne nämlich an einem Elternhaus, möchte
in einem zweiten Tag einen zweiten Anschluss, was willst du haben, Kabel, nichts, nicht viel,
was brauchst du, Kabel oder Telefon, du brauchst übrigens keinen zweiten Internetanschluss,
dein Internetanschluss ist nach wie vor im Keller, du brauchst einfach die Möglichkeit
deinen Router da oben anzustöpseln und selbst wenn, du kannst theoretisch deinen Router auch
im Keller stöpseln und einfach einen Netzwerkkabel hochlegen und dann dort dein Switch dran
machen, also wirklich einen zweiten Internetanschluss, machen wir nicht Kabel, ja gut, das ist ja
kein Ding, Unity Media kommt unten aus dem Keller raus, hat unten im Keller seine Verstärker
und Geschiss und von dort müsstest du halt einen Coax Kabel bei dir in den ersten Stock
legen, wenn du das willst oder brauchst, das muss kein explizit Internetanschluss sein,
das Internet kommt ja nach wie vor, also Unity Media oder Wodafone, das kommt ja nach wie
vor aus der Straße in deinen Keller, von dort dann hängt dann meistens irgendwie ein Verstärker
oder wie auch immer diese Dinger genau bei Unity Media und Wodafone heißen und dort
kommt dann ein ganz normales Coax Kabel raus und das müsste halt dann dort hoch bei dir
in den ersten Stock, brauchst da keinen explizit Internetanschluss im ersten Stock, was du
auch machen kannst ist, das Unity Media Connect Box im Keller anschließen und einfach ganz
normal einen Netzwerkkabel zu legen vom Keller in den ersten Stock, dann hast du halt den
Router im Keller und Netzwerk bei dir oben im ersten Stock per Kabel, hat den Vorteil,
du hast auch gleich Netzwerk im Keller, falls du da irgendwas anschließen willst, gibt
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, ja und wenn es DSL ist, gibt es noch einen Anschluss, wenn
es DSL ist, dann ist es relativ einfach, weil DSL sind ja bloß zwei Kupferkabel, das ist
ja Fluch und Segen von DSL zeitgleich, DSL ist easy as fuck zu verlegen und anzuschließen
aber dafür ist DSL limitiert. DSL ist einfach, DSL musst du gar nichts machen, sondern dort
wo das Telefonkabel bei dir unten, da ist meistens so ein Auflegefeld, dort wo das rauskommt
bei dir im Keller, machst du ein Kabel drauf, zwei Adern, zack hoch im ersten Stock, da
ist aber auch ein Netzwerkkabel am besten, da hast du nämlich acht Adern drin und dann
dafür brauchst du zwei Stück fürs Telefon, also du brauchst keinen Internetanschluss
im ersten Stock, du musst lediglich das, was rauskommt im Keller, ja entweder direkt
per Netzwerkkabel oder halt per Coax Kabel und dann den Router bei dir im ersten Stock
dranschließen. Was übrigens schwierig ist, ohne Leerrohre vom Keller im ersten Stock
zu kommen, das kann ich dir aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, es sei denn du hast schon was, wenn
du schon Kabel hast, dann würde ich es davon abhängig machen, was du schon für Kabel
liegen hast, wie ich das mache. So, also wir lassen uns mal eine Runde von LevelCaptureBane,
kurz Chat gucken, ich habe bestimmt wieder die Hälfte übersehen. Ja, also ich sage
euch, wenn ihr mir nicht mehr den Internetausbau und das Gelaber bei uns angucke, ich gehe
davon aus, dass meine Enkelkinder, falls ich welche haben sollte, dass meine Enkelkinder
noch sich überlegen, wie man am besten DSL da macht und legt und Zeug, das werden wir
wahrscheinlich nie los werden. So sieht es aus. Moin. Ich mache keine Reddit-Posts auf,
da weiß man nie, was einen erwartet. Wobei, der geht tatsächlich. Verspätung ca. 530
Minuten. Ok, das ist Chebathe, aber, oder meint ihr, das ist echt? Das könnte einfach
die Bewegung sein, aber das kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Diese Woche in Frankfurt gesehen,
Renten statt Raketen, da wüsste ich überhaupt nicht, was mir das überhaupt sagen soll.
Was soll mir das überhaupt sagen? Wollen die weniger Ausgaben für Raumfahrt, wollen
die weniger Ausgaben fürs Militär, dafür mehr Rente oder was soll mir das, da wüsste
ich bei diesem Buch gar nicht, was ich sagen soll. Man kann da sau viel rein interpretieren,
keine Ahnung. Ja, gut, dass die jetzt alle was von Renten schreiben, ist ja klar. Es
wird bald gewählt und Rentner haben wir viele. Ja, und kein Feuermag mehr heißt ja nicht,
dass die Rentner mehr Geld bekommen. Scheuert. Also mal ganz kurz Chat durch scrollen. Was
ist aus Bitborn geworden? Ich wollte es ja nur mal ausprobieren für Stream zum angucken.
Ich hatte nie ernsthaft vor, das zu verwenden. Gibt es die überhaupt noch? Hat er das wieder
dicht gemacht? Nee, gibt es nicht mehr. Hat er wieder ein Problem gehabt, dass die Leute
Pornes hochgeladen haben oder wie? Wie bei dieser Visual Studio Code Extension? Hast
schon mal gesehen. Ja, ja, ja. Okay, gut, da lassen wir uns jetzt von von Level Cap Jibayden.
Elon Musk soll unsere Rente bezahlen. Elon Musk hat ja schwer, hat ja. Also, also Elon
Musk rechnet, glaube ich, mit vielen Sachen, aber nicht mit der deutschen Bürokratie.
Wenn es um den Bau von seiner. Wie heißt das Ding Gigafactory in? Ich habe schon wieder
vergessen, wo das ist. Geht. Damit hat er nicht gerechnet. Er hat gedacht, wir gehen
dahin, wir füllen paar Formulare aus und dann baue ich das Ding. So, der hat nicht damit
gerechnet, dass es solche großen Probleme geben wird, in Deutschland so ein Ding hinzubauen.
Übrigens, das muss ich jetzt einfach sagen. Wisst ihr, was ich bei diesem Bau von Gigafactory
nicht nicht bei den Grün Heide, Grün Heide, genau. Also, wisst ihr, was ich daran wirklich
lustig finde? Das ist was, was uns in Zukunft zwangsläufig, unabhängig davon, ob man das
gut oder schlecht findet. Aber das wird uns in Zukunft öfters passieren. Und zwar, dass
quasi, wie umschreibe ich das denn am besten, dass quasi Leute, die früher an einem Strang
gezogen haben, jetzt gegeneinander arbeiten werden. Zum Beispiel Umweltschutz. Ja, also
bisher war das ja immer so, dass quasi Umweltschutz und Tierschutz und nachhaltige Energie und
sowas, das ging immer so ein bisschen Hand in Hand. Das wird in Zukunft nicht mehr so
sein. Überlegt euch mal, was da jetzt passiert. Die Grünen und sag mal so viele Pro-Energiewende
und sonstige Leute sind natürlich dafür, dass wir Elektroautos in Deutschland produzieren
und dementsprechend sind die Grünen glaube ich sogar ganz offiziell auch für diese Gigafactory
in Grün Heide. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du Umweltschützer und lokale Bürgerbewegungen,
die sagen, ja okay, da gibt es wieder irgendwelche seltenen Viecher und das Grundwasser und
sonst wie. Also sprich, du wirst in Zukunft öfters den Konflikt haben, so in den eigenen
Reihen. Da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf. So nach dem Motto Umweltschützer versus Umweltschützer
wird es dann geben. Weil die einen sagen, hey, die seltene Froschsorte muss geschützt
werden, die dürfen wir nicht umsiedeln und die anderen sagen, ja aber hier brauchen wir
was für Elektroautos oder hier brauchen wir irgendwie Wasserkraft oder hier brauchen wir
Windkraft oder Solar oder sonst was. Dann kommen die anderen wieder und sagen, nein, aber hier
ist die seltene Libellensorte. Also das wird in Zukunft noch richtig, ähm, richtige Flame
Wars geben. Umweltschützer versus Umweltschützer. Und jeder der beiden Seiten, das ist ja besonders
witzig immer, jeder der beiden Seiten sagt, seine Ansicht der Dinge ist komplett alternativ
los. Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt. Jetzt werden uns früher oder später aber
definitiv ins Haus stehen, ja. Also da kommen wir nicht drum herum. Was hältst du von einem
Balkonkraftwerk? Hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht. Chat sagt, das sind eher
urbane Ökos versus Landökos. Ich glaube, man kann das alles nicht so klassifizieren.
Aber das werden wir schon sehen, dass Leute dann sagen, wir bauen jetzt da Wasserkraft
oder Windkraft oder Solar oder so hin und dann gibt es wieder andere, die sich an Bäumen
festketten und sagen, den Wald darf man nicht abholzen und sowas. Garantiert 100%. Das wird
nicht ausbleiben die nächsten paar Jahre. Wobei ich ja immer schon überrascht war, dass
die, ich kann mich doch dunkel grade erinnern, bei uns gab es mal hier in der Nähe irgendeine,
das ist schon keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre her oder so, da gab es mal eine Demo gegen Atomkraft
und da haben die Leute sich wieder festgekettet mit, das war hier irgendwo am Main. Irgendwie,
es ist ja nicht so weit weg, war ja ein Atomkraftwerk. Zumindest, da gab es eine Demo gegen Atomkraft
und da war auch wieder irgendein Transport oder so und was damals relativ angesagt war,
dass die Leute, die besonders energisch versus Atomkraft waren, sich angekettet haben an
den Gleisen. Also sie haben sich dann irgendwie da mit Handschellen oder so festgemacht, den
Schlüssel geschluckt oder keine Ahnung, dass die halt die Züge nicht weiterfahren können.
So und dann hatten sie, das hätt ich mir echt live gern angeguckt, dann hatten sie aber
irgendwie das Problem, normalerweise ist es dann so, der Kram bleibt halt stehen. So und
dann hatten sie irgendwelche, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, Weichenstörungen oder sonst was
und dann hatten sie das Problem, dass die Leute nicht mehr weg konnten. Also quasi normalerweise
bleibt das Ding stehen, normalerweise bleibt das Ding stehen und die Leute sind angekettet
und irgendwie hatten sie halt das Problem, dass sie nicht garantieren konnten, dass das
Ding jetzt halt da gar nicht langfährt und dann haben die alle ein bisschen Panik gekriegt,
die angekettet waren. So und auch die Motto, fuck, fuck vielleicht bleibt jetzt der Zug
nicht stehen und dann müssen sie wohl alle Panik geschoben haben und wollten sich relativ
schnell wieder abketten. Aber gut, das hätt ich mir gerne angeguckt. Nichtsdestotrotz
bin ich natürlich dafür, dass wir sinnvollerweise aus diesem ganzen Scheiß aussteigen, sei es
Kohle oder Atom, wobei ich die Reihenfolge nicht so ganz verstehe. Ich mein bei Kohle
ist ja ganz offensichtlich, du hast ganz viel CO2 und Dreck, was du rausbläst, bei Atom
hast du das Problem, du musst irgendwie mit dem Müll hin. So das sind halt die zwei grundsätzlichen
Probleme, wobei ich die Reihenfolge nicht verstehe. Also von der Logik her, also wenn
man sagt, wir haben nur noch ganz wenig Zeit, auch nur halbwegs was gegen Klimawandel, Katastrophe
und Erwärmung und so was jetzt unmittelbar zu machen, dann wäre die logische Konsequenz,
man schaltet jetzt instant erstmal Kohle ab und lässt Atomkraft und so noch ein bisschen
laufen, weil umgedreht ist ja bescheuert. Unfallgefahr, ja genau, aber umgedreht ist ja bescheuert,
weil du hast zwar langfristig sicherlich mehr Probleme mit Atomkraftwerken, aber kurzfristig
hast du auf jeden Fall mehr Probleme mit Kohlekraftwerken. Naja egal, aber wie gesagt hier Umweltschutz
versus Umweltschutz wird es auf jeden Fall die nächsten Jahre immer mehr geben, da haben
da Leute, die Ketten sich an Bäumen fassen und die anderen sagen, nein ihr müsst jetzt
weg, weil hier muss irgendwie Windkraft hin, da bin ich echt gespannt drauf. Ja Kernfusion
wäre eine coole Sache, Kernfusion wäre in der Tat eine coole Sache, allerdings sind
wir da noch nicht so weit, dass wir da sinnvoll was machen können. Also ich glaube das beste,
was man bisher bei Kernfusion geschafft hat, ist irgendwie ein paar Minuten, dass der Reaktor
oder ich bin mir noch gar nicht mehr sicher, ob man das schon geschafft hat, aber ich glaube
wir sind so gerade ungefähr auf diesem Entwicklungsstand. Kernfusion ist glaube ich das neueste vom
neuesten an Erkenntnissen, dass wir es gerade mal geschafft haben, dass ein paar Minuten
lang oder vielleicht sogar noch ein paar Sekunden lang, also nur ganz kurze Zeit, der Reaktor
läuft und ungefähr so viel Strom liefert, wie er selbst braucht. Also bevor wir Kernfusionskraftwerke
bauen, die auch wirklich viel versorgen, das wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern.
Und zwar auch wenn da immer erzählt wird, in 10 Jahren ist es so weit, das hat man vor
10 Jahren auch schon erzählt. Wendelstein baut gerade auf 30 Minuten um. Ja das irgendwie
so in dem Dreh, genau also ich habe mitbekommen, dass bei den letzten, bei diesen letzten Kernfusionsversuchen,
wir haben ein paar Experimentaufbauten, das beste was sie bisher geschafft haben, ist eine
kurze Zeit den Reaktor laufen zu lassen und dass der ungefähr so viel Energie produziert
hat, wie er selbst braucht. Ich meine damit machst du natürlich kein Kraftwerk, ist ja
klar. Weil was brauchst du denn ein Kraftwerk, was gerade mal sich selbst versorgen kann.
Die Katze ist fake, no shit.
Ja gut das machen wir ja eh schon. Ja ich weiß doch, die haben sich festgekettet, früher
an, also das war hier am Main das Atomkraftwerk, das ist nicht so weit weg, die haben sich
festgekettet und dann hatten sie halt das Problem, vielleicht haben die auch nur getrollt, keine
Ahnung, dann hatten sie das Problem, dass die Weichen nicht richtig funktioniert haben,
normalerweise halten diese Transporte ja oder fahren da gar nicht lang und da konnten sie
irgendwie nicht mehr garantieren, dass sie jetzt nicht über die Demonstrierenden drüber
fahren und ihr hättet mal sehen müssen, kann ich da noch an die Nachrichten erinnern,
wie schnell die Leute wieder weg wollten, weil überfahren lassen wollte sich natürlich
da niemand bei. Aber letztendlich finde ich es ja gut, wenn die Leute da für das demonstrieren,
wovon sie überzeugt sind, finde ich vollkommen in Ordnung, habe ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen
mit und ich finde Atomstrom sicherlich auch nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss. Also über
kurz oder lang kommen wir nicht drumherum den ganzen Scheiß auf irgendwas Nachhaltiges
und Umweltschonendes umzustellen. Ist halt nur die Frage, was aktuell akuter ist. Ok,
wir lassen uns jetzt einfach anfangen eine Dyson-Sphäre zu bauen, natürlich, das ist
gar kein Ding, machen wir, easy. Erstmal kurz, die gesamte, also wir sind ja raumfahrtechnisch
gerade so gut dabei, wir sollten erstmal die gesamte Sonne mit Minisatelliten umgeben,
easy, gar kein Problem. Machen wir mit unserer aktuellen Technik, naja, komplett problemlos.
Ich würde sagen, wir sollten einfach Starlink umfunktionieren. Genau, wo ist das Problem,
kannst du was zu Wac, Woogl sagen, nee, was ist das, sag ich nicht, ich sag mir nichts.
A self-hosted ad-free privacy-respecting meta-search-engine, na gut, selbst-hosted Suchmaschinen gibt's
schon ganz lange, das Problem ist, dass denen schlicht und ergreifend der Index fehlt, der
Google Index und das Google Ranking und der Google Algorithmus. Eine Suchmaschine zu bauen
ist nicht schwer, also Suchmaschinen zu bauen ist, also rein von den prinzipiellen Sachen
von Textindizieren ist kein großartiges Problem. Das zu ranken und einen großen Index zu haben
und sinnvolle Suchergebnisse zu liefern, ja, das ist schon wieder was anderes. Also eine
Volltextsuche zu bauen, also mit Basic Funktion ist nicht schwierig, gute Ergebnisse zu liefern
ist, was man sucht, wenn man sich nur einfach nach Wörtern sucht, das ist tatsächlich
schwierig und da hat Google halt einfach die Nase vorne. So, wir lassen uns jetzt jebaiten
von Levelcap. Was jebaitet uns Levelcap? Mal kurz gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt. Das
hab ich mir vor zwei Jahren oder so mal gekauft auf Steam, ich hab außer der Trainingsmission
noch nie was gespielt. Auf jebaitet uns. Das Game juckt mich null. Und was, jetzt schon,
jetzt schon.
Insurgency Sandstorm
Ja, das soll richtig gut sein.
Ich stell mir das mit Konsolen eben vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig vor.
Des
cross-platform mod.io service for its mods and this means mods developed for the
sandstorm is unreal 3 noch ne
pc version could be released for console players too
sandstorm has tons of incredible mods that rework weapons, add new maps, offer original
maps and even total conversions like ismc that makes the game more hardcore and realistic
overall it's a fascinating time for tactical fps fans
sandstorm might not be as big as call of duty or battlefield but it's a strong contender
for one of the best hardcore fps games around launching on console will bring a whole new
wave of players that may have never was ist das eigentlich für komisches gameplay da im
hintergrund
realistic tactical fps game before of course insurgency isn't the only tactical fps coming
to console this year world war two shooter hell let loose is currently in the middle
of its first closed beta on playstation 5 the game is a success on pc and is a standout
historical title it's likely launching during the holiday season this year unfortunately
for people interested the beta is under strict nda so there isn't much info available about
it from the players that's it of course ich muss euch muss euch was erzählen ea hat wieder
zugeschlagen ich habe eine mail bekommen ob ich nicht an einem internen battlefield 2042
ist also nix nda darf ich erzählen ob ich nicht an einem battlefield 2042 pre hands-on blood
test mitmachen will frag mich nicht wie das ding jetzt genau heißt so haben sie gemeint
ja willst du mitmachen habe ich klar mache ich mit easy habe ich richtig bock drauf und
nächste frage war wie sind dann wie sind dann meine pc specs habe ich gesagt ach passt
schon ich habe 1008 ti 8 800k 32 g ram 2 terabyte ssd sollte sollte kein problem sein und auf
einmal bekomme ich eine mail wo dann drinne steht max wie ist denn deine adresse wir schicken
dir den pc zu leihweise zu für für diesen battlefield test nee da habe ich jetzt keinen
bock drauf warum wollt ihr mir den pc zuschicken ich kann das ich kann das doch bei mir spielen
ich also da bin ich raus ich will kein ich will kein pc ich will mein setup setup nicht
ändern und und dann ist rausgekommen warum sie mir den pc schicken wollten die leute
die sich das eingeguckt haben ich glaube die sind jetzt hartwerte ist ja nix verwerfliches
dran aber die sind jetzt hardware speck technisch nicht so versiert und die haben halt gesehen
mindestanforderungen ist eine rtx 2060 und die haben halt gesehen ich habe eine 1080 ti
1080 ist kleiner als 2060 und haben gesagt ich erfülle nicht die mindestanforderungen
bis da wo ich sag nee nee nee leute die 1080 ti ist ungefähr 50 prozent schneller als
ein 2060 und meine cpu ist auch mindestens 50 prozent schneller als die mindest cpu passt
schon das läuft bei mir alles macht euch keine genackten gramm habe ich auch doppelt so viel
stellt euch mal vor wenn 8700k und 1080 ti nicht laufen nicht genügen würde um das
ding in low details wenigstens zu spielen und ich werde es eh definitiv in low details
spielen weil low details gleich mehr fps ja aber jetzt habe ich ich habe sie überzeugt
davon dass ich auch ohne probleme mit meinem rechner daran teilnehmen kann der viel besser
ist als die mindestanforderungen die wussten es einfach nicht besser wenn man einfach nur
wenn man einfach nur zahlen vergleicht ist ja klar was ist deiner meinung nach aktuell
das beste mmo da kann ich nichts zu sagen weil ich habe schon eine ganze weile nicht
mal wirklich intensiv mmo 24 steven kreisel geheimnis das kommt als nächstes oldschool
rutscheff dieses game interessiert mich so absolut gar nicht vor allem vor allem weil
es der dates creator ist und dates ist ja nie richtig fertig geworden
äh
und
Und obwohl es wert ist, zu sagen, dass das eine gemeinsame Praxis ist und nicht genau heißt,
dass Battlefield 2042 Spieler an einem schweren Zeitpunkt am Tag 1 sind, ist es immer noch bemerkenswert.
EA war letztendlich die Täter eines Cyber-Attackes, wo die Source-Code für FIFA 21 und den Frostbite-Engine
wurden gestohlen. Die Haken sagen, dass sie einen Exploit haben, der für die meisten Frostbite-Games funktioniert.
Aber richtig sicher ist nur etwas, wenn du weißt, wie es funktioniert und du kannst es trotzdem nicht knacken.
Guck dir den ordentlichen Save an. Da kannst du dir die Baupläne angucken im Internet, aber du kannst den Save trotzdem nicht knacken.
So müsste das sein. Oder auch bei Verschlüsselung. Du weißt genau, wie der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus funktioniert,
aber du kannst ihn trotzdem nicht knacken, nur durch das Wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Also wenn was wirklich ordentlich secure gemacht ist, dann kannst du wissen, wie es funktioniert, ohne dass du es knacken kannst.
Das ist natürlich jetzt, was Anti-Cheats angeht, ein bisschen problematisch, weil da ist vieles Security by obscurity.
Wir versuchen es wirklich zu verschleiern.
Gott sei Dank gibt es auf der Konsole auch die alten Call of Duty-Teile an und sonst wie was. Das ist alles nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, dazu hättest du den Source-Politik nicht gebraucht.
Wie gesagt, die Zukunft der Cheats ist eh was anderes. Die Zukunft der Cheats ist externes Device AI trainiert. Dann wird es schwierig.
Battlefield hat Cosplay, ja.
Was sagt er jetzt?
Deswegen, das ist ja der Grund, deswegen brauchst du Custom Server mit auch Custom Plugins, dass du diesem Cheating-Kack herwirst.
Okay, was?
Juckt mich nicht.
Ah ja, habe ich gesehen.
Habe ich gesehen, hat mich auch nicht gejuckt.
Was auch immer das jetzt genau heißen soll.
Was für ein Ding? Was habe ich denn schon wieder verpasst auf Twitch? Was ist denn schon wieder los? Was ist denn, wer ist warum schon wieder triggert? Was ist denn? Was habe ich denn verpasst wieder?
Hate Raids? Was geht denn schon wieder ab?
Hate Raids haben in den letzten wenigen Wochen ein noch größeres Problem für die Plattform geworden. Der offizielle Twitch-Channel wird...
Wenn ich sagen würde, also der Frazier, den kann ich überhaupt nicht ab, dann würde ich den raiden und bevor ich quasi off gehe, sage ich, Leute, wir raiden jetzt XY, den kann ich überhaupt nicht ab, voller Spaß, macht den mal fertig, oder wie? Ist das dann ein Hate Raid?
Das ist ja bescheuert.
Wobei ich gar nicht verstehe, warum man da nichts gegen machen kann, ist doch easy, das nachzuvollziehen, wer da wen gehatet hat. Ich meine, natürlich ist es Kindergarten, aber das nachzuvollziehen ist doch easy.
Was ist alles gibt?
Mal davon abgesehen, wenn die anderen Leute ein paar Mods haben, dann machen sie halt Follower-only-10-Minuten-Chat und nach einer halben Stunde sind die Leute doch wieder weg?
Das war auch gute Games.
Echt? Ist das so? Ist Fallout mittlerweile an well-liked MMO?
Ist das so? Spielt das noch jemand? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe mir das nie näher angeguckt. Ist Fallout 76 mittlerweile well-liked?
Hat jemand von euch diese Gamescom Eröffnungszeremonie geguckt? Ich muss sagen, ich war so gelangweilt an dem Abend und habe es trotzdem nicht geguckt, weil es mich null interessiert hat.
War ultra-trash, habe ich mir gedacht. Hacker-Modus gestartet hier.
Du hast jetzt bei Lost angeschaut, war mega-trash. Gut, da ist es ja gut, dass ich nicht gestreamt habe. Ich habe überlegt, ob ich streamen soll, aber wie gesagt, mir war es sogar so langweilig an dem Abend, dass ich mir gedacht habe, guckst du dir das an? Aber nein, nein, nein, nein. Das wollte ich dann doch nicht.
Das hätte mich noch mehr geguckt. Während ich das geguckt hätte, obwohl es mir vorher schon langweiliger war, wäre es mir während dem Schauen noch langweiliger gewesen.
Ja, dieser Pokemon Fake oder Fake, das ist jetzt unfair, das zu nennen, dieses Pokemon inspirierte Monster-Sammel-Game, das sah tatsächlich ganz interessant aus, weil es im Vergleich zum aktuellen für die Switch gezeigten Pokemon grafisch zumindest ein bisschen was hermacht.
Und ich rede jetzt von grafisch was hermachen, nicht der Unterschied zwischen den Konsolen. Klar, kannst du maximal auf einer Switch weniger machen als sagen wir auf einer PS5 oder auf einem PC, aber es geht ja um den Style und mit wieviel Details und wie aus einem Guster Spiel ist.
Und das neue Pokemon, sage sogar ich als jemand, der diese Spiele nie großartig gespielt hat und ein paar Sachen nicht gesehen hat, die Bäume sehen aus wie Half-Life 1 Bäume, die ich damals im Level-Editor gesetzt habe.
So, was kriegen wir dann hier schönes empfohlen noch? Zeig mal her, YouTube. YouTube, jetzt ist deine Chance, kannst du noch was Gutes empfehlen.
How Green Screen Worked Before Computers, es interessiert mich nicht. Black Ops Cold War vs Modern Warfare. Besser als 3D Druck, das Video kenne ich schon, das interessiert mich nicht so.
How do you use Windows?
Ja, irgendwie YouTube nicht so geil, was man da heute bekommt.
Home Assistant OS, lieber auf dem Raspberry Pi 3 oder 4 laufen lassen. Naja, wenn du zwar zur Auswahl hast neben den 4er, aber wichtig ist, dass du es auf eine SSD machst, weil über MicroSD ist es fucking langsam.
If Appleman. Hast du das Video von Sam Zockt gesehen? Ja, habe ich gesehen, an voll und ganz recht. LeChark1978, 2 Monate Hypersubscription hier, nicht 2, 20.
Leichter Raspberry Pi 3 für Nextcloud aus, klar. Je nachdem, die Sache ist natürlich immer, die man hinzufügen muss, je nachdem, was du machen willst.
Twitch Streamers und... Ach, das ist das oder was? Okay, habe ich nicht mitbekommen, juckt mich auch nicht.
Darf ich nicht angucken, sonst Monka Toss. Okay, was ist das? 60 Sekunden Video, please angucken. Okay, Zeit mal her.
Was ist denn SF Office? Oh, Hacker Man, Wim Hacker Man, endlich, so geht das. Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Mal kurz schauen, ist das Python? Ja, das ist Python und Shit History. Shit. Ja, so würde ich das auch machen, wenn sobald der Test fehlschlägt, ist ja ganz klar, dass es am Test liegt und nicht an dem, was man programmiert hat.
Das sehe ich auch so.
Das ist übrigens eines der Sachen, die ich zu einem großen Teil auf der Arbeit mache. Das, was er hier macht. Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Das geht mir teilweise auch so. Das geht mir. Essen auch, ja Essen auch, natürlich. Essen und Pull-Request reviewen. Wobei bei uns heißt das natürlich, es ist ja ein Merchrequest, kein Pull-Request, weil es ist ja in Bitbucket, alles im gleichen Repo.
Aber das geht mir auch so. Ich gucke mir das an und denke mir, okay, du wirst schon wissen, was du machst.
Genau so läuft es, so sieht es aus. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich nicht reinschreibe, looks good to me, sondern einfach direkt auf approved klicke und dann wird es instant gemercht. Je nachdem, ob ich Bock habe oder meine Admin vor allem gerade offen ist und ich direkt merchen kann.
Ich merche nie, ich merche nie über das Web-Interface.
LGTM looks good to me. Ja, heißt das.
LGTM.
Oder auch LGTM. LGTM. So, also, was haben wir denn sonst noch? YouTube. YouTube kann uns heute wieder echt nichts Scheiß empfehlen.
Nix, nix dabei. Linux-User installen einen Web-Browser ab. Pac-Man installen Chrome oder Firefox oder so oder was auch immer.
Yup, install, zack, Browser da. Er hatte vorher schon Firefox installiert, null, jebaited-Video.
Okay, was können wir sonst noch so angucken? Der Lockpicking-Lawyer. Attrap. Sebaro. Wo ist er denn?
Hacked. Microwave-Transformer becomes hacked. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum mir das empfohlen wurde.
Aber nachdem es nur 5 Minuten lang ist, gucken wir uns das jetzt an, wie er ein Microwave-Transformer hacked.
Sebaro ist gar nicht mehr am Start. Ja, ich glaube, der ist mit seinem Studio beschäftigt.
Anlöten. Oder anschweißen. Ja, das geht auch. Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Schweißen sind, wisst ihr, was ich letzte Woche gemacht habe?
Ich habe zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben Rohre miteinander verlötet. Zinkrohre von der Regenrinne.
Das musste ich oben abschneiden, weil es verstopft war. Abschneiden, abmachen, sauber machen, wieder dran.
Und ob hartlöten oder weichlöten, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich kann euch sagen, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Bzw. besser gesagt, ich habe Glück, dass mein Nachbar solche Dinge hat. Ich hätte sie nicht da gehabt.
Ich hätte auch keine Ahnung gehabt, wie das funktioniert. Also manchmal ist es tatsächlich ganz praktisch, dass man einen Nachbar hat.
Also wie das funktioniert hat, man braucht einen Tank mit Gas. Man braucht so einen Brenner.
Brenner mit vorne so einem Metallstück dran. Wie heißt denn das?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Ja, der hintere Teil sieht so aus, so ähnlich, bloß dass man einen Schlauch dran hat.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das, wie das, hm, warte mal. Blöd, Kolben, Zinkrohre.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Ne, ne, ne, sieht anders aus.
Das ist, das sieht aus wie dieser Brenner. Das sieht aus wie dieser Brenner. Nur, dass davor noch ein Stück Metall ist.
Und das ist erstmal gar nicht so easy zu checken, wie das funktioniert. Moment, wir gucken jetzt einfach mal Video.
Da gibt es noch bestimmt Videos. Weichlöten, Zinkblech, eine Anleitung. Ja, genau. Das klingt auch gut.
Dachrinne löten. Ja, genau. So ein Ding. Nur, dass das hier nicht so ein komisches, äh, so eine Axt war, sondern vorne so ein, ja, so ein Haufen drauf war.
Also hier, das, das hier ist der Brenner. Hier ist der Schlauch zum Tank. Das ist der Brenner. Der Brenner macht das Metall, äh, das Metall, was ist denn das wahrscheinlich? Kupfer oder? Ne, das wird nicht Kupfer. Doch, wahrscheinlich ist das. Was ist denn das da vorne? Kupfer? Ich vermute mal Kupfer.
Ähm, macht das heiß und dann musst du, dann musst du dann, ähm, das hier ist, das hier ist, ähm, Flussmittel. Also Flux, wie man auch bei normalen Nöten für kleine, für kleine Teile, Kabel und so teilweise mal verwendet.
Wobei für Kabel weniger, für irgendwelche Komponenten auf dem, auf dem Board oder so. Das ist, das ist quasi so ein, so ein, so ein Fluss, so ein Flussmittel. Dann hast du hier das, äh, dein, dein Lütz hin oder was das, was das ist.
So. Und dann, das schmierst du mal gucken. Wir gucken, wir gucken uns das an. So. Ne, das hab ich nicht gemacht. Ich hab hier nur, ich hab hier nur, ich hab hier nur, ich hab hier nur ein Rohr zugemacht. So.
Genau. Du musst den Kram einschmieren, dass es ordentlich läuft.
Äh, abputzen, das ist ja sowas.
Wie gesagt, ich, ich, ich konnte froh sein, dass mein Nachbar Ahnung hat, wie das funktioniert. Der hat keine Ahnung gehabt.
So.
Genau. Und jetzt hältst du das da dran. Und dadurch, dass du Flussmittel unten dran hast, läuft das dann schön.
Regenrinnenstellz. Ja, ich hab so Rohr zusammengemacht. Genau. So. Und was ich machen musste ist, was, was er jetzt hier nicht macht, wahrscheinlich, weil das zwei Teile sind, die ordentlich zusammenpassen. Ich musste mega fest draufdrücken, dass das ordentlich zusammengeht, weil ich hab das Rohr.
Also. Paint. Paintstellz. Die, die Regenrinne. Also. Massive. So hier. Regenrinne. So. Hier, hier Dach. Hier ist das Dach. So, das ist die Regenrinne.
Und dann gibt es dann hier das Rohr. Das Rohr geht runter. So. Das Rohr besteht im Prinzip aus einzelnen Rohren. Die sind hier so zusammengemacht mit einer Manschette an der Wand.
So. Und unten. Ist dann so ein Ding. So. Und so. Und das hier habe ich abgemacht aus Versehen. Das ist abgebrochen.
Das ist abgebrochen. Also ich hab das hier abgemacht von der Wand. Hab das abgeschnitten, weil das ganze Rohr war voller Dreck. Da ist nichts mehr durchgemacht. In welcher Höhe auf dem Boden?
Ein Meter oder so. So. Und dann hab ich versucht das hier rauszudrehen. Das ging nicht. Dann hab ich den Big Brain Move gemacht. Ich hab mir gedacht, okay, nachdem ich die Manschette aufgemacht hab, hab ich mir gedacht, das muss doch abgehen.
Und dann hab ich hier unten 5-6 Mal draufgetreten. Weil ich mir gedacht hab, ach, easy, das geht doch nur. Man braucht ordentlich Kraft, dann geht das ab. Und dann ist es hier abgebrochen.
Ist einfach mittendurchgebrochen. So. Und daraufhin, nachdem ich weiß, mein Nachbar ist Dachdecker. Und dazu hat er es zumindest gelernt.
Ich sag mal, hast du eine Idee? Ja klar, hier, machen wir. Also man braucht dazu einen Tank mit Gas. Man braucht dazu einen Lötkolb, wobei der ein bisschen anders aussah.
Und man braucht hier halt so Lötzinn. Weil ich gar nicht weiß, ob das Zinn ist. Ich würde da mal drauf tippen.
So. Das Problem, was ich hatte, ist jetzt, dass hier in der Regengräne kannst du da easy innen drin löten. Aber wir mussten ja quasi das hier wieder zusammen löten.
Das war gar nicht so einfach. Was wir jetzt gemacht haben, ist, wir haben einfach übelst fest draufgedrückt, die Teile gegeneinander. Und dann hab ich hier also zusammengehalten.
Da muss man sich gar nicht so viel... Das Rohr wird gar nicht wirklich großartig heiß. So. Megafest zusammengedrückt, das Rohr. Und dann einfach drum herum versucht, das irgendwie zusammenzulöten.
Und das hat funktioniert. Das ist bombenfest, Leute. Bombenfest. Natürlich sieht das nicht so schön aus, wie bei ihm hier. Der weiß, wie man das macht.
Übrigens, wir haben auch eine Sache nicht richtig gemacht. Normalerweise musst du das Rohr ordentlich sauber machen.
Dass das alles gut hält. Wir haben das nicht richtig sauber gemacht. Das ist ein Rohr, das hängt da seit 30 Jahren. Das ist voll im Arsch.
Ein bisschen sauber gemacht. Aber es hält. Es ist wirklich bombenfest.
Und wie sag ich, das macht mega Spaß. Ich würd's nicht jeden Tag machen wollen. Aber so eins, das macht echt Spaß, so Kram zusammenzulöten.
3.000 Euro Schaden. Ja, das ist RIP. Ah, ihr seid da bestimmt versichert. Also so langsam hab ich das nicht gemacht. Ich bin da schneller drüber.
Ja. Und ich sag euch, Leute, das sieht so geil aus. Okay, geil ist vielleicht das falsche Wort. Aber das sieht so hypnotisierend aus. Wenn man da drauf guckt und man hinter oder so schräg vor seinem Lötkolben so ne Spur, so ne Spur Lötzin hinterher schiebt, zieht.
Und wenn man dann von oben drauf guckt, sieht man, wie das dann so 3, 4, 5 Sekunden später hart wird und quasi so von der entgegengesetzten Seite dann so durchzieht.
Das sieht richtig hypnotisch aus. Weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt hier sieht. Weil noch ist das ja flüssig. So und nach ein paar Sekunden zieht es dann durch und wird hart.
Ja, das ist schon hart. Na egal. Ich muss das jetzt nicht jeden Tag machen, aber es ist poggers. Das fühlt sich richtig geil an, wenn das dann auch funktioniert und hält. Und ich sag euch, das ist bombenfest. Ich hab danach ein bisschen dran rumgerobbt, nichts mehr abgegangen.
Satisfying, genau. Da könnte man so ein Satisfying Videokompilation draus machen. Ja, man sieht es hier ein bisschen. Guckt mal, wenn es hart wird, kriegt es eine andere Farbe, wie wenn es flüssig ist. Das zieht dann so durch.
Okay, jetzt wird es hart hier und das zieht das richtig hypnotisch irgendwie. So, wunderbar. Wollte ich euch nochmal erzählen. Jetzt habe ich auch schon mal Rohre gelötet.
Ach ja und, was ich auch gelernt habe, man hatte den Brenner und den Schlauch an dem Gastank dran. Was ich auch gelernt habe ist, das habe ich in einem YouTube Video gesehen danach, weil ich habe mir danach noch ein paar YouTube Videos angeguckt, dass man in Wirklichkeit, normalerweise gibt es eine Verordnung, Vorschrift oder so für Baustellen,
dass du mindestens glaub einen 5 Meter Schlauch brauchst zwischen Gastank und Brenner. Also du musst deinen Gastank mindestens 5 Meter quasi vom Brenner wechseln. Das haben wir nicht gemacht, obwohl er hätte das eigentlich wissen müssen.
Das ist eine Vorschrift, weil, naja, es will halt keiner den Gastank anzünden. So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was der...
Boah, what the... Das funktioniert danach noch?
Mokka meldt? Funktioniert doch. Das funktioniert doch im Leben nicht. Wobei, natürlich funktioniert das, sonst hätte er kein Video drüber gemacht, aber, naja, ein wenig übersteuert.
Er und Electro Boom sind aber auch die einzigen, die auf die Idee kommen, aus ihrer Mikrowelle ein Schweißgerät zu bauen, oder?
Was ist das? Zeig mal. Was ist das für ein Widerstand? 5W2K7. Was bedeutet das jetzt?
5W2K7? Ist das was? 2,7 Kiloohm. Also 2700 oder was? Oder wie viel?
Ist das viel?
Aha.
17 Volt ist aber nicht so viel.
Ah, Moment. Der hat aus 2 Volt, hat er 17,2 gemacht. Okay. Ja, das bedeutet natürlich... Oh, da kommt einiges vor.
Uri, genau. Ich weiß nicht, für mich sieht das irgendwie so aus, als möchte ich das Ding danach nicht mehr verwenden nach dieser Behandlung.
Ja, sowas, so einen Teil habe ich auch. Ist äußerst praktisch.
Lol, Alter. Jetzt will er es wissen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das allen Ernstes danach noch mal anschließen würde, aber okay.
Okay, er muss da auf jeden Fall jetzt ja irgendwie eine neue Spule... Ah, jetzt. Alter, was ein fettes Kabel.
Wupp Boom? Wie ist mein Wupp-Schock-Emote? Wupp-Boom, genau.
Universal Stabelektrode umhüllt. Ist das ein Deutscher? Ich dachte es ist ein Australier oder sowas.
Ja. Okay, wusste ich gar nicht. Ich dachte immer aus irgendwelchen Gründen es ist ein Australier, nicht wegen dem Akzent, sondern weil ich das glaube irgendwo, dachte ich habe das irgendwo mal gelesen, dass die aus Austral...
Die E-Block oder wie das heißt, ist Australier. Das bringe ich jetzt gerade durcheinander. Okay, dann habe ich das jetzt durcheinander gebracht.
RIP.
Das hatte ich schon immer mal vor, ja. Also ich wollte schon immer mal, ich meine nicht Electro-Boom, ich meine Eve-Block, das was gerade im Chat gepostet wurde. Ich wollte schon immer mal einen Transformer aus der Mikrowelle umbauen, dass ich den Pinsel aufheizen kann. Ja, ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Noch fetter.
Das ist bestimmt krebserregend was man da einatmet beim Abschneiden.
Na ja, wirklich.
Oh. Wirklich ein Video wo es am Ende nicht funktioniert, das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Weil normalerweise weißt du am Anfang immer wenn einer ein Video macht das funktioniert.
Alles klar, jetzt weiß ich schon mal was ich definitiv nicht machen werde mit meiner alten Mikrowelle.
Das ist mir zu Wupps Smoke.
Warum Internet in Deutschland so lahm ist, das wurde mir, ich habe, ganz ehrlich, ich habe davor noch nie was wirklich großartig geguckt. Ich weiß nur, dass das der Channel ist von diesem Typ, der früher auch beim WDR Computer Club, also das noch älter als ich, die Sendung gemacht hat, wurde mir heute Morgen empfohlen auf ein Tablet.
Keine Ahnung ob das was, ob das was taugt. Mal gucken, mal gucken. Dann haben wir noch Tour durch Smart, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Tour durch das Smart Home 2021. Da kann ich, da kann ich meinen Senf zugeben.
Dann haben wir noch den Hour, Solar Panels und, und Zeug. Da kann ich meinen Senf zugeben. Hometic, oh ne da habe ich keine Ahnung von. Das ist ja komplett Hometic, da habe ich keinen Plan von. Kann ich gar nichts zu sagen.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt den Bauer an. Wir haben tatsächlich eine 6900 XT in die CNC Fräse gepackt. Auf geht's. Fräschamp.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video. Wir schauen uns heute diese Karte an. Ihr kennt die 6900 XT hier. Die ist aus dem Hochwasser PC von Matthias und die hatte einen Transportschaden und zwar hier unten. Seht ihr, das ist eine rissende Platine und immer wenn man die einbaut in das System, dann ist direkt OCP oder, keine Ahnung, Kurzschluss Stromschutz auf jeden Fall bei dem Netzteil.
Das bedeutet, sobald man die versucht... Das ist doch nice. Kurzschluss ist immer gut. Dann geht das Netzteil aus, weil anscheinend irgendwo in der Platine ein Kurzschluss vorhanden ist. Das versuchen wir heute mal zu fixen. Schauen wir mal, was wir da machen können. Wir werden später versuchen, das hier rauszumachen. Aber erstmal werden wir so ein bisschen checken, wie sieht die Karte denn aus von den Widerständen zum Beispiel.
Dragonplayer sagt... Oh ja, übrigens heute Mittag, jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe, heute Nachmittag Hetzner Stream Nummer 2. So ab, wahrscheinlich so 16 Uhr. Jetzt wo ich gerade die Werbung von ihm sehe. Heute Mittag Hetzner Stream.
Dragonplayer sagt, er muss sich eine neue GPU kaufen. Meine 970 stirbt. Ja, viel Spaß mit den aktuellen Preisen. Sehen so deren DCs aus. Du kannst, wenn du dir das Rechenzentrum, das Hetzner Rechenzentrum, Rundgang...
Wenn du dir die Cloud, das ist ja kein extra Rechenzentrum nur für die Cloud. Wenn du die Hetzner Cloud Räume angucken willst, kannst du dir die hier, die haben extra so einen Rundgang, wo du durchs Rechenzentrum laufen kannst.
Dann kannst du hier rein, dann kannst du hier durchlaufen. Dann kannst du dir das angucken. Dann weißt du wie es bei Hetzner Cloud ausschaut.
Das ist wirklich cool gemacht. So, der Auer, wo ist er denn?
Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie lange der Bauer Sellout macht.
Lass mal kurz gucken, ab wann, ab wann geht's los.
Werden wir so ein bisschen checken, wie sieht die Karte denn aus von den Widerständen zum Beispiel.
Okay, bei 45 geht's los.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Hetzner mit dem Dedicated Root Server AX41. Hetzner betreibt seine Rechenzentren für Privat- und Geschäftskunden in Deutschland und Finnland und legt dabei großen Wert auf die aktuellsten technischen Standards und gleichzeitig auch den Fokus auf die Umwelt, wie zum Beispiel durch Verwenden von 100% Ökostrom.
Der AX41 ist das Einstiegsmodell der Dedicated Root Server und ist standardmäßig mit dem Ryzen 5 3600 6K Prozessor, 64 GB RAM und 2 512 GB in Form E-SSDs ausgeschattet.
Das komplette Rackdesign und speziell auch die Kühlung sind komplett von Hetzner in Deutschland entwickelt und bieten neben 24-7-Support eine schnelle Internetanbindung.
Okay, okay, der macht das ungefähr so lang wie ich auch.
Mehr findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Also 30 Sekunden, äh 40 Sekunden.
Um in Widerstände zu messen, um zu schauen, ob irgendwo ein Kurzschluss vorliegt und das ist bei einer aktuellen Grafikkarte immer nicht ganz so einfach.
Hier oben dieser Punkt, also da sind so Kondensatoren dazwischen, hier ist einer frei.
Wenn wir das hier messen, das ist eigentlich der RAM.
Das sieht original aus, wie die Sensoren, die ich auch bei meinem Multimeter habe.
Ich habe mir nämlich extra bei Amazon noch so ein Packen gekauft, extra flexible vom Kabel her, mit Klemmen, mit, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die unterschiedlichen Aufsätze heißen.
Also einmal mit diesen normalen Sensoren, dann mit Klemmen, dann noch sind irgendwie vier, fünf verschiedene Dinger.
Richtig nice, weil die haben halt äußerst super flexible Kabel.
Wie viel bekommt man für 40 Sekunden?
Ähm, ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen, aber ich kann dir sagen, dass es nicht anhand der Zeit wirklich genau gemessen wird.
Also wir haben nicht gesagt, ich muss mindestens 30, mindestens 40 oder sonst viel was machen, sondern einfach, dass es passt.
Prüfspitzen genau.
Das ist eigentlich der RAM. Also wir messen jetzt den In-Video schon vom RAM.
24,5 Ohm, ganz typischer Wert.
Natürlich, klar, dachte ich mir auch.
RAM immer was zwischen 20 und 24 Ohm, der RAM Widerstand, ganz klar.
So als Richtwert für euch, falls ihr das mal zu Hause checken wollt.
Na klar, wollte ich ja immer mal checken.
Beim RAM, bei der Spannungsversorgung vom RAM liegt kein Kurzschluss vor, das sehen wir dadurch schon.
Problematisch ist das Ganze jetzt, wenn wir...
Leute kommen Continuous Deployments oder was wird heute Abend gemacht?
Ich hab leider mein To-Do nicht da.
Also heute machen wir auf jeden Fall...
Die Anwendung kriegt noch irgendeine API-Abfrage.
Dann machen wir Zertifikate.
Und wir bauen einen CACW SSS Service Load Balancer davor.
Wie das mit dem Deployment wird, muss ich mal gucken.
CACW SSS Service Load Balancer ist natürlich das Allerwichtigste.
Das muss ja hoch skalierbar, horizontal, vertikal und diagonal skalierbar sein, was wir da programmiert haben.
Wenn wir von der GPU messen wollen.
Das hier ist Teil der GPU Spannungsversorgung.
Das heißt, wenn wir zwischen hier wieder Masse...
Also Masse ist hier links und rechts ist die GPU Spannung.
Also das geht direkt zur GPU, das heißt wir messen zwischen GPU und Masse.
Wenn wir das jetzt messen, dann seht ihr 0 Ohm, 0,1 Ohm vielleicht.
Und wenn man das jetzt so misst, denkt man sich auf jeden Fall, verdammt, da könnte ein Kurzschluss vorliegen.
Also gerade mit so günstigen Multimetern, sage ich mal, kann man so kleine...
Man kann doch Kurzschluss...
Kann man die Dinger, Leute ihr wisst, dass ich elektrotechnikmäßig nicht so...
Aber ich kann bei meinem Multimeter einstellen, dass es piepst, wenn es einen Kurzschluss hat.
Also wenn ich dann die beiden Dinger zusammen mache, dann piepst es.
Also das muss man auf den richtigen Modus schalten.
Schnell zum falschen Ergebnis.
Und bevor Leute wieder rumheulen und sagen, man kann den obensten Widerstand von einem Halbleiter so nicht messen,
das mag vielleicht richtig sein, aber das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Es geht nur um Vergleichswerte.
Wir wollen ja nur wissen, liegt da ein Kurzschluss vor oder nicht?
Und ob wir jetzt da zum Beispiel bei dem RAM 24 Ohm auslesen und das der reelle Wert ist,
oder ob da 18 Ohm dran ist und das dann der reelle Wert wäre,
das spielt gar keine Rolle, weil wir vergleichen am Ende nur Masse zu Masse und Masse zu GPU,
Masse zu Memory, wir vergleichen nur.
Das heißt, wir wollen nur wissen, liegt da ein Kurzschluss vor oder nicht?
Hast du einen von Techlife?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe irgendein nicht allzu teures Ding von Amazon.
Wert stimmt oder nicht, das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Um den GPU Innenwiderstand zu messen, haben wir dieses wunderschöne Teil hier.
Das ist ein Milliohmmeter.
Und damit können wir eben Widerstände im Milliohmbereich messen.
Ja gut, sowas habe ich nicht, das ist zu teuer.
Das sind schon die Messleitungen, das sind schon ganz andere.
Wir haben hier Vierleitermesstechnik, das heißt,
dadurch, dass wir hier vier verschiedene Leiter haben,
kann das Messgerät erstmal den Widerstand von der Leitung an sich rauscanceln, rausrechnen.
Das ist schon mal ganz, ganz wichtig.
Big brain Multimeter.
Wenn man eben über Vierleitertechnik das machen kann mit zwei Leitern,
kann das Messgerät nicht wissen, wie hoch der Innenwiderstand von den Leitungen ist.
Das ist schon mal wichtig, um ein korrekteres Ergebnis zu bekommen.
Im Idealfall würden wir das jetzt hier hinten auf der Rückseite von der GPU messen,
also da wo diese ganzen kleinen Kondensatoren sind, das wäre das Beste.
Problematisch ist allerdings, dass diese Zangen hier von der Größe einfach zu hoch sind.
Wird ein bisschen schwierig, ja.
Oder nicht so einfach anklemmen, deswegen bedienen wir uns wieder den Punkten hier
und da löte ich jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz zwei kleine Pins an,
an denen wir dann ganz bequem das hier anschließen können,
weil es ist wichtig, dass auch beide Seiten Kontakt haben
und nicht nur eine ansonsten funktioniert.
Sehr gute, sehr gutes Lützchen.
Exakt die gleiche Rolle habe ich auch hier.
Wirklich, genau, gleicher Hersteller, gleiche Größe, gleicher Durchmesser.
Genau das gleiche Teil.
Das ist das, was Amazon als erstes ausspuckt, wenn du ein Lützchen suchst.
Ist das ein TS 80 oder ein TS 100 oder sowas, was er hier hat?
Nee, das ist was, was per Kabel.
Bin ich froh, dass ich mir für die für diese Erser Lützstation,
also für den Lötkolben dabei, dass ich mir jetzt endlich mal
ein paar ordentliche Spitzen gekauft habe.
Die Standardspitze ist ja vollkommen okay.
Aber er hat auch ein Erser.
Nice, habe ich auch.
Siehste, der weiß, was gut ist.
Und da habe ich mir jetzt ein paar neue Spitzen gekauft,
dass ich beispielsweise so kleinen Scheiß auch ordentlich löten kann.
Ich habe jetzt insgesamt drei, also mit der Default Spitze habe ich vier.
Runter bis irgendwie zwei Millimeter oder so.
Das ist dann deutlich angenehmer.
Kannst du ein Löt-Set empfehlen?
Ja, ich kann dir nur das empfehlen, was ich habe.
Und das ist aber wirklich äußerst nice.
Finde ich ganz richtig, richtig super.
Nano ist es, glaube ich.
Aber das ist halt ein bisschen teuer.
Also ich würde mir nicht random so ein Teil kaufen,
wenn man das nicht öfters mal braucht.
Das praktische an dem Set oder an der Lütstation ist halt,
du hast nicht wie bei so einem fetten Lötkolben jetzt so ein Teil
mit unflexiblem Stromkabel oder sonst was dran.
Du hast hier deine Lütstation, da kannst du halt alles einstellen,
was du brauchst.
Du kannst sogar eine Micro SD-Karte reinmachen mit unterschiedlichen
Temperaturpresets und alle möglichen möglichen Kram.
Stellst du hier die Tastik.
Also erstens, das Ding heizt mega schnell auf.
Das braucht fünf Sekunden, dann ist das auf 400 Grad.
Das geht jetzt flutscht richtig.
Das heizt super schnell aus,
hat automatische Abschaltmechanik und sowas.
So und du hast halt den Vorteil,
dadurch, dass du hier dieses getrennte Ding hast,
du hast hier keine Kabel dazwischen rumfuddeln.
Das Lötkolben ist halt per Kabel hier rechts an dieser Station dran,
sieht man jetzt hier an der Stelle nicht.
Und da kannst du hier links deinen Halter oder rechts,
oder je nachdem, wie du das anordnen willst, hinstellen.
Und du hast halt hier diesen Lötkolben,
der ist halt an einem super flexiblen Kabel
und der Lötkolben an sich ist halt auch klein.
Also wenn du die mal von der Größe vergleichst,
der Lötkolben ist, keine Ahnung, ein Fünftel so groß wie normaler Lötkolben.
Und hat auch Spitzen, die du tauschen kannst und sowas.
Genau, hier so ein kleines Spitzenset hatte ich mir noch geholt.
Und das ist halt super, ja.
Übrigens mit Draht dabei ist bescheuert, Draht kostet nichts.
Lötzen.
Also die kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Also, weil es die einzige ist, die ich hier habe und getestet habe,
die funktioniert super.
Ich habe damit nie irgendwelche Probleme gehabt.
Das hat macht alles genau, was ich will.
Wobei man halt sagen muss für,
man lötet mal gelegentlich irgendwie ein Kabel zusammen,
ist halt vielleicht 200 Euro.
Und das ist halt super,
jetzt nicht unbedingt der Sweetspot so am Preis.
Wer hat das gefragt mit dem Set?
Also Stuhlmorger, ich weiß nicht,
ob das preislich in deiner Vorstellungskategorie irgendwie passt.
Aber das ist die Einzige, die ich wirklich empfehlen kann,
weil das ist die, die ich habe und wunderbar.
Funktioniert das Ganze.
Ja, das ist die einzige, die ich empfehlen kann,
weil das ist die, die ich habe und wunderbar.
Funktioniert das Ganze.
Weiter.
Lötstells.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, dass hier links Masse ist.
Der hat eine Wellerlötstation, der Auer.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal Messungen zwischen Masse und Masse.
Wir wissen, dass hier die unteren Pins vom Stromstecker,
das ist auch Ground.
Das heißt, dann machen wir den hier erstmal hin.
Das ist bestimmt so ein Hybrid-Ding, was er hat mit Heißluft und Lötkollen, oder?
Den da hin.
Und schauen wir mal, was uns das Messgerät anzeigt.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier 1,92 Milliohm.
Das ist eigentlich gar nichts, aber das passt sehr, sehr gut,
weil wir Masse zu Masse messen,
es ist eine direkte Verbindung durch die Platine.
Da haben wir schon mal einen Referenzwert, was einen Kurzschluss bedeuten würde.
Jetzt ändern wir das mal auf den GPU-Widerstand und schauen, was da passiert.
Da sehen wir, es ist definitiv ein anderer Wert.
Weil es ist sehr, sehr wenig.
Also wir haben jetzt 95 Milliohm.
Das erklärt auch, warum unser normales Multimeter 0 Ohm angezeigt hat,
weil das einfach ein Widerstand ist,
denn ein normales Multimeter einfach nicht erfassen kann.
Aber wozu hat man so eine schöne Maschine?
Also versuchen wir gleich mal die gebrauchene Stelle rauszufräsen.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt.
Das war der Halter.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt, wenn sie da rumfräsen wollen an der Grafikkarte.
Ich meine, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Die Dinger sind ja super genau.
Also mal gucken.
Und das benutzen wir jetzt einfach als Opfer-Teil.
Opfer. Alte Opfer-Laden.
Und werden dann versuchen, hier mit dem Fräser ganz fein auf so eine kleine Tasche hier reinzumachen.
Was hältst du vom Dienst Pushover für Push-Notifications auf iOS?
Das habe ich einmal verwendet.
Ist ganz nice.
Man bezahlt allerdings Lizenzgebühren pro Gerät.
Man muss sich das Gerät registrieren und muss dann quasi pro Gerät bezahlen.
Was aber echt in Ordnung ist.
So, Löcher mitgeben.
Das sind drin.
Und jetzt noch die passenden Schrauben finden.
Drauf packen. Und dann haben wir schon mal unsere Montagevorrichtung.
So, damit das CUT auch in der Fressmaschine drin ist,
musst du nur die Kanten antasten.
Und dann fräsen wir hier einfach so ein kleines Stückchen raus.
Ich dachte erst, dass wir nur so eine Mini-Nude machen.
Aber dann bleibt hier so wenig stehen, dass das Teil hier abfallen würde.
Deswegen schneiden wir das einfach komplett so raus.
Zum Viereck. Und dann mal schauen.
So.
Racechamp.
Oh.
So Maschinen sind schon cool, ne?
Das war echt Pock.
Es geht los.
Pass über am Zahnarzt.
Oh.
Ah.
OK.
Was?
Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist?
Hä?
Was?
Was genau macht er denn da?
Ach.
Der will hier das aufreden.
Der will hier das auffräsen, oder was?
Dass man hier irgendwie reingucken kann, oder was?
Wir sind zwar durch, aber ich hoffe, man kann das sehen.
Wenn man die Layer in der Platine betrachtet,
dann ist da auf jeden Fall noch was verschoben.
Also da ist noch ein Riss, der sichtbar ist.
Das heißt, wir müssen mal ein Stück weiter reinfräsen.
OK.
Racechamp.
Hier sehen wir jetzt die Kante nochmal unter dem Makroobjektiv.
Also ordentlich vergrößert.
Da sieht man einfach, dass im rechten Bereich
immer noch die Platine so ein bisschen aufgebrochen ist.
Und man sieht auch, wie hier die Lagen ineinander innen verschoben sind.
Und das führt dann letztendlich, oder kann letztendlich,
zum Kurzschuss führen, je nachdem was das für Lagen sind.
Die Mittleren sind ganz häufig auch einfach nur Masse.
Und wenn die gegeneinander verschoben sind,
ist das erstmal kein Problem.
Aber hier rechts unten sah das eher nicht so gut aus.
Das Problem ist, wir können jetzt erstmal
eigentlich nicht wirklich tiefer reinfräsen,
weil oben drüber direkt an der Kante
läuft schon die erste Leiterbahn lang.
Eigentlich müssten wir noch so einen Millimeter wegnehmen
da unten, dass das alles weg ist, aber...
Ob das am Ende funktioniert?
Schwierig. Wir werden es erstmal probieren, ob es so funktioniert.
Der GPU-Innenwiderstand ist immer noch der gleiche.
Also unbeeinflusst, das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Das heißt, wir haben da soweit erstmal nichts befähigt.
Nichts kaputt gemacht.
Man könnte natürlich viele andere Sachen auch noch nachmessen
und schauen, ob es da ein Problem gibt.
Weil ich keine Referenzwerte dazu habe.
Deswegen werden wir die jetzt einfach mal wieder einbauen
und schauen, ob es was gebracht hat
oder ob wir immer noch direkt den Shutdown haben.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Also die Karte ist jetzt wieder soweit einfach mit dem System verbunden.
Erstmal schön flüssig Stickstoff rein.
Wobei, nee, das macht er ja nur als Passivkühler drauf,
dass es mal kurz angeht, oder nicht?
Ich muss keinen Kühler montieren.
Flüssig Stickstoffkühler drauf.
Alles angeschlossen, wir schauen, was passiert.
Einfach großer Metallblock.
Wir haben schon mal nicht direkt...
Shutdown?
Okay.
Bleibt immer noch bei Grafikkartenerkennung hängen.
Schade.
Vielleicht soll mehr kaputt.
Wir checken mal eben GPU-Spannung.
Die vorhanden ist.
Aber das sieht gut aus. 0,9 Volt.
Dann kurz die Memory-Spannung mal checken.
Hier oben.
1,35 Volt.
Also Spannung scheint da zu sein.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Dementsprechend auch Kurzschluss behoben.
Also keine Ahnung, warum es trotzdem nicht erkannt wird.
Es ist natürlich trotzdem möglich, dass es noch mehr Schaden hier unten ist.
PC-Express.
Also was PC-Express bedeutet.
Broken IF.
Noch kurz letzter Test ohne Riser-Kabel.
Um sicher zu gehen, dass es daran nicht liegt.
Also die GPU wird auf jeden Fall warm.
Das spüre ich am Finger.
Sieht aber nicht gut aus.
Ist immer noch Grafikkartenerkennung.
Ich habe jetzt mal alle Lanes noch abgeklebt,
auf X1.
Gute Idee.
Da wäre ich gar nicht drauf gekommen.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte betreiben,
mit den vorderen PC-Express-Lanes.
Das reicht ja.
Kann man da keinen Stromschlag bekommen?
Nee.
Du kannst, wenn du es doof anfasst,
kannst du die Grafikkarte kurz schließen.
Ja, da musst du aufpassen.
Aber du kriegst da keinen Stromschlag.
Dafür reicht das ja im Rechner alles gar nicht aus.
Was ist denn das Maximale,
was man so im Rechner hat?
12 Volt DC?
Das ist ja nichts.
Da kann ja nichts passieren.
Außer du greifst
ins Netzteil, wo das umgewandelt wird.
Ja, das ist natürlich keine allzu gute Idee.
Aber ansonsten kann dir da eigentlich
im Rechner nichts passieren.
Du kannst es kaputt machen,
aber dir kann nichts passieren.
Nö.
Nope.
F.
Man weiß ja nie.
Jo, äh, nee.
Schade, dass es nicht funktioniert hat.
Ich habe übrigens Matthias gefragt,
wie das Ganze passiert ist.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass bei der Flut der ganze PC
in der Wohnung quasi umgefallen ist.
Also durch das Wasser wurde der Tisch,
wo der drauf stand, komplett umgeworfen.
Natürlich ist quasi der ganze PC
von der normalen Tischhöhe auf den Boden gefallen.
Ja, das kann natürlich so eine Karte
absolut permanent beschädigen.
Mal abgesehen von dem Rissen der Platine.
Das ist schlecht.
Ich denke mal, so behoben haben, weil ansonsten hätte
die Karte ja nicht mehr gestartet. Ich denke mir,
der Kurzschluss an sich ist weg, aber
keine Ahnung.
Kann halt auch alles Mögliche noch sein,
dass irgendwie die GPU sich an einen blöden Punkt
von der Platine ein bisschen gelöst hat.
Irgendein RAM-Chip ist alles möglich.
Das zu debacken mit
Reflow-Tools. Heute der Video,
heute der Tag der erfolglosen Bastelvideos.
Ja, schon. Das sind natürlich nicht immer
100% von Erfolg gekrönt, aber
wir wissen auf jeden Fall, dass GPU und RAM
an sich eigentlich noch funktionieren
könnten, weil
werden warm, kein Kurzschluss ist da.
Aber ja,
damit bin ich immer... Einfach als Heizung verwenden.
Mal am Ende. Ich glaube,
es war draußen interessant. Macht's gut, bis dahin.
Ciao.
Es geht heutzutage um Nachhaltigkeit.
Da kann man nicht einfach alte Grafiken wegschmeißen.
Man kann damit heizen.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt als nächstes?
Terminal Editors.
So, was gucken wir jetzt an?
Den Lockpicking Lawyer.
Der Sebaro wieder.
Smart Home Control Panel.
Warum Internet in Deutschland so lahm ist?
Gut, den gucken wir uns nicht an.
Der verwendet HomeMatic. Da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Was soll ich jetzt zu sagen?
Solar Panels.
Warum unser Rentensystem
am Ende ist.
Ist wahrscheinlich wieder voll übertrieben, das Video.
Zumindest macht er ja gerne die Videos.
Nee, Moment. Jetzt habe ich mich jetzt verwechselt.
Das ist ja Simplicissimus, der immer so
ein wenig übertreibt mit
den Formulierungen.
Nicht...
Oder eher auch. Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich kann die alle nicht mehr auseinanderhalten mittlerweile.
Ich blick dann immer durch.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Ich gucke erstmal kurz in den Chat rein.
Hast du schon mal versucht,
die Stromsteckdose zu upgraden?
Was verstehst du
unter Stromsteckdose zum Upgraden?
Du meinst so eine Steckdose
in die Steckdose, die man über das WLAN schalten kann
oder so?
Ah, da habe ich ein paar am Start. Da haben wir sogar
extrem schon dran rumgebastelt.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo ich versucht habe,
die eine Steckdose auseinanderzubauen?
Und am Ende, nachdem ich die komplett
auseinandergerobbt habe, festgestellt habe, vorne
wäre eine Schraube gewesen.
Das aufzumachen.
Ja, da brauchst du eine Kokona-Steckdose.
Nein, nein, so eine richtig, richtig
die echte Stromdose zu ändern, um die
Oberlichtlampe zu schalten.
Du meinst den Relay
in den Relay in den
in den Lichtschalter, unter den Lichtschalter
in die Dose einbauen, oder wie?
Was kannst du machen? Da brauchst du zum Beispiel
sowas hier.
Das sind kleine Relays, die kannst du
in die Dose einbauen an der Wand.
So hier.
Da schließt du dann den Schalter dran an.
Und, sag mal mal, die Leitungen,
die zur Lampe gehen.
Und dann kannst du die Lampe sowohl
mit dem Relay, also
dann kannst du dir das Relay hier drinnen,
was die Lampe schaltet, kannst du mit dem Schalter
schalten.
Ja, davon hab ich auch ein paar da.
Die sind wirklich nice.
Kannst du Shelly für Rollladen in der
Mietwohnung empfehlen? Nein, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich nicht am Start.
Hab ich nicht, hab ich nicht im Einsatz, keine Ahnung.
Kann ich nicht so sagen. Also ich hab
ich hab einige Shelly 1 da,
ich hab auch ein paar Shelly 1L da,
aber ich hab auch ein paar Shelly 1L da,
also ich hab auch ein paar Shelly 1L da,
ich hab auch ein paar Shelly 1L da,
aber die hab ich noch nirgendwo angeschlossen.
Ich hab einen Shelly 1PM, das ist,
äh, der kann Strom messen und so was.
Ähm, und
das war's glaube.
2,5 noch hab.
Das war's. Nee, aber die Dinger sind wirklich cool.
Nee, für Rollladen, nee, dann hab ich keinen 2,5.
Ah, so ein Refling
für Shelly, nein.
Sollte man, sollte man
aber mal generieren, ja.
Ja, das
ist nicht ohne. Also die, die Shellys
einzubauen, die sind tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne.
Zumal die, das würde ich
mir machen lassen.
Zumal die
Anschlussdiagramme, die hier sind,
auch jetzt unbedingt
nicht für jeden verständlich sind.
Wo
haben sie denn überhaupt ein Anschlussdiagramm?
Support?
Hallo?
Diagramm.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so ohne
die Shellys anzuschließen.
Ja, das hier ist zum Beispiel ohne
Schalter dabei.
Ja, das hier, das hier ist, das hier
ist glaube ich ganz gut. Aber ja, das ist
tatsächlich nicht so ohne. Und
ich würde da nicht dran rumfuddeln. Ich meine,
du kannst das machen, du musst aber auf jeden Fall, also
bevor du irgendwas machst,
mach die Sicherung raus. Das
kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Und teste auch, dass es, dass da
Strom weg ist, ja.
Und zwar nicht mit irgendwie
so einem Phasenprüfer
oder wie diese kleinen Dinge heißen, sondern
du brauchst dann so einen,
also einen Multimeter solltest du eh haben, aber
um zu testen, ob kein Strom da drauf ist, ist das
das Beste, was du haben kannst, zu einem, ähm,
wie heißt das Ding? So was
da? So ein Teil.
Da kannst du testen, ob wirklich
alles aus ist.
Ich habe da nämlich auch immer
richtig Schiss davor. Deswegen
habe ich mir, deswegen habe ich mir mal so ein bisschen
Equipment gekauft, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen,
dass zumindest das Strom
aus ist, ja.
Dann hältst du das rein,
in die Steckdose
und wenn das nichts mehr
anzeigt, dann ist der Strom wirklich aus.
So, und dann kannst du
die Shellys anschließen. Ich meine, klar, du kannst das
selbst machen.
Gerade dort, wo man Sicherungen
ausschalten kann, ich meine, da kann ja nicht allzu viel passieren.
Zumindest unmittelbar nicht.
Aber trotzdem,
ähm,
ich würde das in der Tat
ein Fachmann machen lassen, wenn ich keine
Ahnung davon habe.
Ich denke mal,
das hält sich preislich auch in Grenzen.
Wenn du dem sagst, du willst, keine Ahnung,
5 so Teile eingebaut haben,
dann rückt der an, macht das dir in der Stunde
und dann ist er wieder weg.
Du kannst
übrigens auch mal, bevor du das,
also, was ich generell
bei allen Bastelarbeiten empfehlen würde,
jetzt nicht, jetzt wirklich, also
erstens mal lasst die Finger weg von 230 Volt,
wenn ihr keine Ahnung habt, das mache ich auch,
mache ich auch so.
Ähm,
also,
mache ich auch so.
Ähm,
aber,
wenn man einfach mal üben will,
dann kann man sowas ja auch mit, ähm,
mit, mit, mit, mit, mit einem
Testaufbau machen, ja.
Und es muss ja noch nicht mal unbedingt jetzt hier eine echte Lampe
mit 230 Volt sein, als wenn man sowas mal üben will
und das kann ich immer nur empfehlen,
bevor man was bastelt, mal einen Testlauf zu machen
und zu gucken,
man kann sowas ja auch am Basteltisch aufbauen,
ja, mit einem Netzteil,
ein paar Vago-Klemmen, einem Shelley
und einem Schalter.
Das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig in der Wand sein,
das kann man mal einen Testaufbau machen, dass man weiß,
ok, wie muss was dran
und, äh,
dann weiß man zumindest schon mal
paar Sachen mehr, als, als wenn man
einfach vor der Dose steht. Also ich, wie gesagt,
ich würde es prinzipiell nicht selbst machen,
wenn ich davon gar keine Ahnung hab, 230 Volt,
kann ich killen und, ähm,
man möchte ja auch nicht, dass das Haus irgendwie
abfackelt, weil man Mist anschließt.
Lass das einfach jemand machen, der das kann
und dann ist easy.
Habt ihr jetzt nicht verstanden,
was die Dinger machen? Also,
was diese Dinger machen, ist, ist folgendes.
Das Problem,
was man hat, wenn man
eine smarte Klübirne einbaut, also
stellt euch vor, ihr habt hier,
ihr habt nen Raum und habt nen Bewegungsmelder.
Und ihr möchtet jetzt,
dass wenn ihr in den Raum kommt, der Bewegungsmelder
Bewegung erkannt hat, dass die,
dass die Lampe an der Decke automatisch
angeht. So, was ihr dazu braucht,
ist irgendwie eine Möglichkeit,
die Lampe an- und auszuschalten.
So, also ihr habt dann ein Heimautomatisierungssystem,
das erkennt dann, Bewegungsmelder
triggert und dann müsst ihr irgendwie sagen,
ok, Bewegungsmelder hat getriggert,
ich, ähm, möchte die Lampe
anschalten. So, das heißt, ihr braucht irgendwie die
Möglichkeit, übers WLAN oder irgendwie
anders, wireless, die Lampe
an- und auszuschalten. Da gibt's jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten
für. Entweder ihr nehmt ne RGB
oder ihr nehmt in irgendeine Art
und Weise ne Wi-Fi Lampe,
Z-Wave Lampe
oder was auch immer, ne Lampe,
die man wireless schalten kann.
Dann macht ihr die rein, meldet die bei euch
im WLAN an und dann könnt ihr die steuern. Das Problem
ist jetzt, wenn jetzt eure
Frau, Freundin, Mutter,
Oma, Opa, wer auch immer,
der das Ganze nicht so durchschaut oder grad nicht so
nachdenkt, an den Lichtschalter
geht und schaltet
die Lampe aus, dann ist die WLAN
Lampe aus und ihr könnt sie nicht wieder
einschalten über eure Heimautomatisierung.
Ist ja logisch, weil die hat keinen Strom
mehr. Das heißt, sobald ihr eine RGB
oder irgendeine WLAN Lampe habt,
könnt ihr den Lichtschalter nicht mehr verwenden.
Der Lichtschalter muss immer an sein
und die Lampe schaltet sich selbstständig an
und aus. Logisch so weit, oder?
Das heißt,
das ist anwendungstechnisch nicht
so easy, nicht
so benutzerfreundlich. So, und ihr
könnt euren Lichtschalter nicht mehr verwenden.
Das heißt, die bessere Variante ist
eigentlich, anstatt die Lampe
über die Lampe per WLAN
ein- und auszuschalten, ist
ein Relay. Also sprich,
du baust
hier so einen Shelley ein. So, und der Shelley
hat mehrere Eingänge. Der hat
einen Eingang für den Schalter,
der hat einen Eingang
für den Strom und er hat einen Eingang
bzw. Output
für dort, wo
die Lampe dran kommt. So, und was
das Shelley macht, ist folgendes.
Entweder du drückst den Schalter,
dann schaltet er hier das Relay durch
oder du
stellst den Shelley über
WLAN ein und schaltest das
Relay über WLAN. Also,
der Shelley schaltet für dich
deine Lampe an- und aus
und dementsprechend kannst du
den Shelley triggern über WLAN
oder über den Schalter. Das heißt,
der Lichtschalter geht danach noch und
das WLAN geht. Also, du kannst
dann auch über das WLAN ein- und ausschalten
mit dem Lichtschalter ein- und ausschalten
und beides reagiert aufeinander.
Also, wenn du über WLAN ausschaltest
und du klippst den Schalter um,
dann kannst du einschalten und sowas. Also,
das ist eine gute
Geschichte.
Besser auf jeden Fall, als nur über die Lampe
auszuschalten und deinen Lichtschalter nicht mal
zu verwenden.
Es gibt WLAN-Lichtschalter,
das ist im Prinzip doch genau das gleiche.
Da ist auch ein Relay drin.
Das ist
genau das gleiche.
Da muss ja auch ein Relay drin sein,
weil ansonsten müsste
in irgendeiner Art und Weise da ein
Motor drin sein, der den Lichtschalter kippt
über WLAN. Das wird nicht so sein.
Wenn du einen WLAN-Lichtschalter kaufst,
dann ist das exakt so was.
Das wird ein Lichtschalter sein
mit einem Relay dabei.
Also, im Prinzip ist das genau das.
Nur, dass du hier alles
so lassen kannst, wie du willst. Und du baust
unter den Lichtschalter oder wenn kein Platz
ist, in die Dose unten drunter wie auch immer
diesen Shelley ein. Die sind nicht groß.
Kann man sich mal angucken.
Hier, Dose. Guckt, seht ihr.
Je nach Dose passt das nicht.
Muss man sich halt mal angucken. Aber normalerweise
ist da Platz.
Die etwas advancedere Variante ist
noch der Shelley 1PM.
Der kann auch messen, wie der Stromverbrauch ist.
So sieht's aus.
Gibt auch physikalische Switche mit Minimotor,
der den Schalter betätigt. Okay.
Warum auch immer. Hat ja eigentlich keinen Vorteil
gegenüber einem Relay.
Gibt es den Shelley auch mit LAN?
Da bist du einer der wenigen
der Netzwerkanschlüsse.
Er hat als WLAN-Abdeckung.
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob es den Shelley
mit
Netzwerk...
Kein Schimmer.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber wenn du
LAN-Kabel hast, dann stoppst du noch einen
Passpoint dahin.
In die Nähe.
Braucht die Shelley einen Taster oder einen
Schalter? Das ist egal.
Es geht beides.
Ja.
Du kannst dann auch einschalten, ob da bei
jedem Schalten
immer
togglet oder ob du
mit einer Position, also das oben immer
an ist und unten immer aus. Und das kann man in der Software
einschalten.
Ich würde sagen, das nimmt
sich nicht so viel. Du musst den alten
Lichtschalter ausbauen, den neuen Lichtschalter
einbauen. Also dir bleibt nichts anderes
übrig, wie Sicherung ausmachen
und das einzufädeln. Und nachdem so
ein Funk-Lichtschalter
wahrscheinlich
auch nur ein Schalter
mit einem Relay drin ist.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich ist das
im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie
ein bestehender Schalter und ein Shelley.
Also du musst
das auf jeden Fall
anstöpseln, weil
wie willst du sonst die Lampe schalten, wenn das nicht angeschlossen ist?
Kann man
den Shelley Factory resetten? Ja.
Ich glaube, man, bin ich mir jetzt aber
nicht sicher. Ich glaube, du kannst
ähm...
Wobei, nee, das war Tasmota mit
speziellen Schalterkombinationen. Ich gehe
mal davon aus, du kannst mit speziellen Schalterkombinationen
den Werks resetten, ja.
Tasmota kannst du, da musst
du siebenmal an- und ausschalten und dann fünf Sekunden
warten oder so und dann kannst du Factory resetten.
Du kannst das Ding aber bestimmt auch
so einstellen, dass es automatisch einen Exist-Point
so einen Fail-Exist-Point
aufmacht, wenn
WLAN wegfliegt.
Du kannst Custom-Firmware
auf die Shelley's draufmalen. Ja, ja, funktioniert auch.
Also du kannst die Dinge hier flashen mit Custom-Firmware.
Aber man muss sagen,
die Shelley-Firmware ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Es gibt einige solcher Sachen, aber
Shelley ist halt eine schöne Kombination aus
klein und
relativ, relativ günstig.
Deswegen, ganz einfach, lasst es jemand einbauen.
Ihr müsst es nicht selber machen. Lasst es ein Elektriker
einbauen. Sagt dem einfach, hier, ich habe
fünf solcher Teile, die ich eingebaut haben will.
Dann macht ihr euch das und dann kostet es zwar ein bisschen
mehr, aber dann könnt ihr euch sicher sein, das ist richtig
einfach.
So. Exzellent.
Weiter geht's. Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
Zeig mal her.
Leute, ich kriege langsam Hunger.
Wir gucken uns jetzt den Lockpicking-Lawyer an.
Der Sebaro wird gepickt.
Two is binding.
Click on three.
Four is binding.
Warum sollte ich
bei Shelley im Betrieb anfangen?
Also,
Vertrieb,
als bin ich gerade derjenige, der
Vertrieb macht. Wenn ich Vertrieb mache,
verkaufen die nichts.
Sie,
Lecki,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay.
Zeig uns.
Cute-Mod.
Zeig her.
Ich meine, das muss schon schwierig sein.
Guck mal, fünf Minuten,
das ist schon schwierig.
Das ist schon schwierig.
Guck mal, fünf Minuten,
das ist für seine Verhältnisse mega lang.
Normalerweise gehen seine Videos zwei Minuten
und er hat das dann irgendwie auf fünf
verschiedene Arten geknackt.
Ups. Eine Maus hat doppelte
Klicks in letzter Zeit.
Sag bloß, dieses Logitech-Ding geht jetzt nach einem Jahr
schon wieder kaputt.
Hör mal bloß auf.
Kann ja auch nicht sein,
dass das Hardware immer nach einem Jahr
schon kaputt geht.
Oder nach zwei.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wann ich die gekauft habe.
Tausche ich die einfach über Amazon um.
Komm, mach auch kurz nebenbei gucken.
Your Orders,
Logitech.
Also,
Die Maus habe ich gekauft.
Die Maus habe ich gekauft. 21. Mai
21. Mai 2020.
Die Maus ist jetzt
ungefähr noch nicht mal ein Jahr und hat jetzt schon doppelte Klicks das kann
doch nicht das kann doch nicht sein
was hat er denn da für Big B alter das ist das der der next level der
next level lockpick den er da am start hat. was zum what?
fünf minuten braucht ist es ist es komplett secure das ist das loch das loch
das loch das ist das ist sicher das ist sicher wenn er dafür so lang braucht
kriegt das der 015 autodeep auch nicht auf. keine chance
ok wenn er dafür so lang braucht das ist das ist safe das schloss ist safe
vor allem wer hat so einen big brain lockpick dabei
ok jetzt kann man nicht mal mehr aufschließen
alter da hast du was zu tun das ist das ist das längste video was ich von ihm
je gesehen habe und das wird als autoschloss
noch nie gesehen
allein schon dass er dafür jetzt fünf minuten gebraucht hat das kriegt der 015 autodeep
überhaupt nicht gebacken aber wobei der 015 autodeep wahrscheinlich die
Scheibe einschlägt oder so. zumindest Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel
das loch ist safe wenn er so lang braucht. wo könnte ich denn meine maus
zurückschicken bei logitech garantie wie geht das hat schon immer mal bei logitech
was zurückgeschickt willkommen beim logitech support rücksendung rückerstattung
wenn ihr produkt defekt ist kontaktieren sie den support austausch
ok wie geht das jetzt wie kriege ich ok ok wo kann ich mich hinwenden wenn meine maus
kaputt ist ich kann bei amazon nicht nachfragen bei amazon bei amazon aber amazon ist ja nach
einem halben jahr verweist sich an den hersteller amazon amazon bei mir steht dabei bei amazon
steht dabei hier link auf logitech bei amazon und tickete öffnen ok ok amazon logitech
maus kaputt was was
wie lange ist die logitech ja ja das haben wir nicht
ich habe keine ahnung was ich machen soll support garantie ja einfach stress auf twitter
machen ja gut das kann ich gut da habe ich übung mittlerweile ich will ich ich will
ich bei kona anrufen produkt support de support über die kaufessung sagt aber mir ich soll
zu logitech gehen ok das muss ich mal ausprobieren habe ich habe ich noch nie gemacht das kann
ich sein dass nach eineinhalb jahren die maus schon doppelte doppelte tasten klicke hat
klicks hat amazon chat support ok das schreibe auf
excellent excellent ein produkt registrieren warum sollte ich das machen warum sollte ich
ein produkt registrieren was habe ich davon was habe ich davon wenn ich mich da wenn ich
das produkt registriere die müssen ja gar nicht coolant sein ich habe ja 22 nicht wirklich
garantie aber ich habe ja 2 jahre wie hast du halbes jahr gewährleistung 2 jahre garantie
ach keine ahnung zumindest ich habe ja 2 jahre dass die dass sie das fixen müssen man klar
wenn man streng streng nimmt müsste ich jetzt irgendwie beweisen dass der fehleranfang noch
nicht vorlag aber darauf lässt ja keine ankommen also immer die da von mir wollen logitech
umtausch amazon was sagt der was gibt es denn da support ist ein fremdwort bei logitech
so so
ich schreibe mal den amazon amazon chat an mal gucken was passiert was der amazon chat
dazu sagt wenn ich sag 2020 maus gekauft ball ja das könnte meine sein die sind belle auch
egal das ist mir egal ob das ewig dauert solange die eine neue maus losschicken bevor
ich die alte hinschicken muss captain ck 16 mona dankeschön das könnte meine sein das
könnte meine sein die denkst du auch noch mensch lass mich in ruhe was kosten eigentlich
eine aktuelle pro wireless
das sehe ich nicht einzukaufen wenn jetzt nach eineinhalb jahren schon kaputt geht image
unavailable die ist die supersiegel die eu version darf man sich angucken ich will
ihn nicht selbst fixen das soll nicht gefällig der hersteller machen ich kaufe mir das ding
an ich für 80 euro dass ich selbst fixen muss innerhalb der ersten zwei jahre
ja so muss es sein so muss es sein
so kann man sonst irgendwas zum angucken also die amazon vorschläge ist in der richtigen
richtig 3 hat gibt es ja überhaupt nichts was ich hier gucken will von
ist ja nur müll dabei ja die dinger sind cool habe ich euch schon öfters erzählt die
dinger sind wirklich nice da hatten wir früher auch viele von wobei das ist ein richtig alter
das ist noch älter als außerdem hatten wir IBM und kein hp die dinger sind richtig big
brain aber leider leider einen hp und kein IBM zu hp kann ich nicht sagen willst du
mal was pfeiffer zum ketten sehen das mit zu big brain ich hatte ja davor also ich muss
ja sagen ich hatte da vorne logitech logitech tastatur nee moment was hatte ich davor ja
doch davor die logitech tastatur wo mir die control taste kaputt gegangen ist davor hatte
ich eine korsart tastatur die doppelte tasten anschläge hatte es gibt wirklich hardware
mäßig es gibt gefühlt nur noch total müll es kann doch nicht sein dass meine maus nach
eineinhalb jahren doppelte doppelte mausklicks hat schon ich habe ich habe dieses ich habe
dieses nähe ich brauche eine logitech maus weil ich habe dieses logitech wireless system
mit aufladbarer also mein maus pett mein maus pett lädt die maus auf das das will ich
weiterhin so haben das ist poc wireless und das maus pett lädt die maus auf so gibt es
sonst noch irgendwas was wir uns hier angucken können perfekt smart home panel juckt mich
jetzt nicht warum warum interne deutschland so lahm ist ok ok auf geht's 22 minuten
endlich mal jemand der es schafft gescheiten sounds raus zu hauen obwohl er im freien ist
versucht es mal lauter zu machen irgendwie aber das funktioniert nicht
ja es geht unter anderem um diesen ja schon etwas mitgenommen aussehenden kasten wollen
ich heute mal über infrastruktur reden nämlich ja wie kommt das internet eigentlich nach hause
da muss es ja irgendwie leitungen geben oder geht es vielleicht per funk oder wie läuft
das eigentlich und da spielt dieser kasten hier doch eine entscheidende rolle dabei jetzt nicht
dieser im speziellen aber die deutsche bundespost und die nachfolgeorganisation haben im laufe der
letzten jahrzehnte quasi im kompletten bundesgebiet solche kasten hier aufgestellt das
sogenannte kabelverzweiger und die zeigen zumindest schon mal an das ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt weiß ich auch warum das so problematisch ist wenn ihr nur ein kasten für ganz deutschland
haben hier entlang und die annahme ist ja stark dass das hier in dieser achse passiert ein kabel
unter der erde liegt zumindest mal ein telefon kabel dann ist und hinterher hingegangen hat
dann auch kabelfernsehen also ein koachs kabel dazu gelegt und mit ein bisschen glück liegt
heute auch ein glasfaserkabel in dieser achse ja hoffentlich schon normalerweise sind die so an
wegen bei uns auf dem land hier im westerwald zum beispiel aber die stehen natürlich auch in
den städten und sie sind natürlich leicht zu übersehen weil sie halt klein grau und hässlich
sind und man dann normalerweise dran vorbeigeht und das gehören die aus bei uns bei uns haben sie
die jetzt bemalt und ich habe den eindruck dass haben irgendwelche zu mit drogen zugedrönten
leute gemalt die bilder das sieht das sieht teilweise zum fürchten aus aber wenn sie mal
drauf achten dann werden sie die natürlich auch in den städten sehen an den straßen rennen an
straßenecken so was verstehen die nicht nicht nicht nicht in regenbogen da ist da ist zum
beispiel eine sonne drauf die aussieht wie die sonne aus mario die so die sich die nicht so gefährlich so ja ein
bisschen so sieht das aus
so so ungefähr sieht die sonne aus ja die da einer drauf gemalt hat nun ja also jetzt wissen
wir hier verlaufen leitungen und es ist anzunehmen dass über diese leitungen auch internet geschah das
ist anzunehmen ja aber das internet muss ja dann auch erst mal hier hinkommen da würde ich sagen
ich folge einfach mal diesen kesten machen wir mal wo wir da rauskommen
so am ende der langen verborgenen leitungen komme ich hier raus an einer stelle sieht man da noch
irgendwas an einem gebäude ich glaube das ist das mega oder sie dann sleeper das video ist was man
früher gesagt hat ein amt oder eine vermittlungsstelle umgangssprachlich heute die
techniker nennen ist technikgebäude und eigentlich in der fachsprache heißt es
hauptverteilung oder kurz hvt das ist also ein gebäude wo aus einem ortsnetz das ist dann
üblicherweise leute das gucke ich mir nicht an das ist das ist das ist mega residents sleeper da
sieht man überhaupt nichts er zeigt die kästen von außen oh nee nee da habe ich keinen bock
drauf dass mit das mit so anstrengend auf dauer nee das muss muss nicht sein das
lgb hauptsache mehr lgb warum so viel lgb die heben ja schon fast ab
ja so darf man das ja auch nicht machen so darf man das ja auch nicht machen
das macht man auch gern wenn ich die hand so von oben hin mal fokussiert aber die beißt
wenigstens nicht richtig bei meiner wenn es die über kommt dann beißt die mir auch schon
mal in die hand aber nicht fest aber halt etwas zu fest zu fest ist schon ok irgendwie gibt es
wieder nix auf youtube was ich mir angucken will ich glaube ich gehe jetzt essen ich habe hunger
ja leute also dann haben wir so ich gehe jetzt essen und heute abend endlich heute abend heute
mittag machen wir dann keck ws service weiter zu 16 uhr um würde ich mal sagen
mir ist jetzt aufgefallen bild bild macht jetzt ganz viel so auf news sendung auf youtube und ich
weiß nicht ob jemand in letzter zeit mal sich beiträge von bild angeguckt hat mich erinnert
dass brutal an fox news aus den usa auch mit die auch mit auch mit diesem duo weibliche
moderatorin männlicher moderator dann immer in den typ zugeschaltet und auch immer gleich den
leuten gesagt wie sie das wie sie was sie dazu denken sollen ab und zu irgendwelche komischen
inanführungslichen diskussionsrunden wo fünf leute quasi immer das gleiche erzählen ist
in laut vielleicht also also das was bild da gerade bringt erinnert mich übelst an fox news
aus den usa ok leute beim zack huge war skills ja also wir sehen uns heute mittag da basteln
weiter bis denn zu